welcome to podcast fellow beautiful
people the Church of what's happening
now is brought to you by my book e dot
AG listen Emma since we started this
podcast people always wanting no [ __ ]
they want to hear about this or that and
this week is it everybody wants in those
101 college who's gonna win Thursday
night who's gonna win Saturday late
who's gonna win the family game on
Sunday night listen let me tell you this
where you're betting is just as
important is who you betting on so
that's why I always tell people to go to
my bookie dot AG listen they're solid
they've been around for a long time and
they've taken care of a lot of us join
my bookie and will match your deposit up
to one hundred percent bonus of your
first deposit up to a thousand dollars
you follow me use promo code Church to
activate the offer visit my bookie dot
AG today and use promo code Church you
play you win and you get paid that's
what it's all about
take that [ __ ] mealy
you
that's where I laugh oh I'm a baby say
back are you [ __ ] me showed me that
from say here's almost 20 of life
no-parole
when you leave the house when you'll
take a [ __ ] out with a skateboard
remember you showed me that concert in a
year when he comes out trigger that's
the opens with a little [ __ ] cape on
yeah I like do to help black people they
always help you with your cape no one
more cape anymore I haven't seen anyone
else busted out next year but anyway
before we start I guess our hearts go
out to South Florida get the [ __ ] out of
there yet open they're sitting there
going listen we swam here we could we
could [ __ ] make it through ever can
hurricane Irma whatever her name is get
the [ __ ] out of there now my heart's
with you the Cubans oil both them
popping bet they're by my pinga it's
time to abandon ship you start now you
could be in Georgia by [ __ ] Saturday
get the [ __ ] out there's not even water
left at Costco in Miami so my dad said
his friend was in a line at a gas
station for nine hours and they just
were out of gas and there were out of
gas yeah it's a night it's no bueno
what's your dad gonna do he's he says
he's fine there he says he has the storm
shutters up his food is water he says
he's gonna be fine
he's got some punk that dad he's got
some stars of death he's got he's got a
little very little sit there for a week
and end up like Jack Nicholson is shiny
and I'll have the full details I tweeted
it out today JetBlue has something where
they're only charging like $99 to do
fights to get out of Florida so check
them out cuz I saw like United was
charging like six thousand or something
oh that's evil really dealt to raise
their prices to Houston Wow I saw United
today from Florida I didn't see Delta
from Houston I bet have to go to Houston
like [ __ ] $9,000 this [ __ ] people like
shame on you Delta Ray what the [ __ ] has
happened to society and that's [ __ ]
out and they use any [ __ ] excuse to
bang me on on gasoline don't they and we
turn first of all first of all they
raise the price of gas ten years ago
fueling up because of the bomb the war
and then they started charging me on the
[ __ ] flights for it then the prices
went down on gas but they continued to
charge me 25 bucks on the [ __ ] flight
we also hear that people all say like oh
the airline industry I don't remember
there's a narrative like four or five
years ago maybe ten years ago oh they're
just losing money they're losing money
that and then every flight you're on is
completely full right every flight
you're on is complete like Las Vegas oh
yeah I just roll everything hello in
Chinese people to put on the white
people in [ __ ] and every flight is
full they throw dreamers off the play
that you might throw messages off the
plan that you're a dreamer get the [ __ ]
off you give it two or three days you're
gonna see a Mexican getting dragged out
of plane by United by his feet well I'm
a dreamer I'm a dreamer but not anymore
you [ __ ] they don't give a [ __ ] you man
they throw everybody you could buy a
[ __ ] stop notorious in [ __ ] 18
years 9/11 was the only time they huh
listen bro I travel every week and they
offer bottle on the Rogan podcast and I
got a thousand emails because people
know I'm not lying you know the reason
why you can't go through TSA with water
how [ __ ] sad is that then a [ __ ]
blah human being works hard for their
money maybe bangs out 50 [ __ ]
grannies
right they want to take their three kids
to [ __ ] Disneyland yeah the [ __ ]
gate they throw away your powder and
they throw away your bottled water then
when you walk in the app what they
charge you 349 for a little tiny [ __ ]
peasant water yep like it's their own
label
yeah listen guys it never ends
and you know what man it always lands on
the little guys pocket always you know
and look at [ __ ] plane tickets and
look at plane tickets though I look at
plane tickets three [ __ ] times a week
we have a place there and the prices on
flights a [ __ ] ridiculous
ladies and gentlemen that hasn't been a
flight I've been on the last two years
and it's not back to the gills
everyone have been on to the [ __ ]
gills the only one that isn't if you do
like if you go from LA to San Jose or
some [ __ ] like that that's it and listen
Southwest flight light the hell it'll be
back yes of course somebody fifty just
think that you're getting that area
right what they're doing to people in
this country it's like what and we were
talking about like Houston well like
that like the disaster stuff is terrible
but what about what they do every year
try to fly home for Christmas try to fly
home for Thanksgiving and the prices are
three times as high
yeah it's it's but just say your say hey
we like making money just beyond it
don't say all we're hurting so that's
what we have to charge more for x y&z
because we the player line industry's
not doing so well right and I get what
happened in Houston I understand what
happened in Houston but the [ __ ]
Harvey hadn't even been to Houston and
they were already telling you gas prices
Brian we're gonna go up tonight before
[ __ ] live even it yeah they were like
what they're really scared over there
when they knew right he came it's
another chance to rape these
[ __ ] because every dime across
the [ __ ] information you figure okay
so Joey so what are you bitching about
the only raise the price of gas 11 cents
think about that per gallon that's a lot
of miles down on tree that's a lot you
know I was telling these guys that they
used to be a captain and again being
those called Pat Conti he only reported
to Paul Castellano Wow
okay I'm the surface he was on the
chairman of the board of war bombs you
hear war bombs a supermarket chain in
New York he was a chanting of a board of
more bombs I don't know how many
supermarkets they had across the country
all crossing these coasts Norcross New
York okay
he was the chairman boy this guy if you
saw a picture of Pat Conti from the
Gambino's you go Joey
he's not a gangster dealers but he was
such a professional he made millions off
at Castellano knew what Castellano took
his envelopes and he played it off like
so what this guy's biggest scam was he
went into every war bounds and built an
extra Heil
I check out like nobody do nothing like
one damn the general manager a wall bomb
coming with a construction still no you
don't get the memo from headquarters
know whatever we're building a new
check-out line
Terry we relieved and the guys like okay
okay and the listen they coming with
paperwork and you have the official wall
bomb station back tot he did that let's
pretend they had let's pretend they had
fifteen supermarkets which we know we
did probably way more way way more yeah
that lot that last line that Aisle
number thirteen right foot went directly
in his pocket at all fifteen super more
and they never close that Lane that was
over twenty four-hour the seven Lane
theater oh yeah and that one on the
other side yep you know that light was
all over Castellano thought he was
getting money from that thirteenth Lane
at twenty five supermarkets right he was
giving me really giving Meryl money sure
sure so that's just to let you know what
a percentage of a percentage does it's
it there's not a little percentage
you've said it yourself joy but I got a
point to have that's fine but if you got
a hundred of those restaurants and you
make a point that yeah that's a
different [ __ ] story is if you own
every gas station and you're charging
eleven cents more for our [ __ ] yeah
ma'am there's a pretty cool series on
Netflix that I watch it's called an
underworld Inc and I watched one today
about like the the pirate trait like
that like the pirates in like in Africa
[Laughter]
so you had time to watch underworld Inc
be them watch Marcos again to support
Gabriel Iglesias
hey come on for the [ __ ] eighth time
I told you yes you try everything like
bro what else can you do his girlfriend
the couple's watch shows together you
but but that don't matter you tell him I
brought the first two more or I had a
city and watch underworld link about
some [ __ ] African pirates Robbins
[ __ ] 14x is very watching Gabriel and
sent them a mail and said Gabriel out of
the [ __ ] Park but no I waited a week
to watch [ __ ] myself and you've had
92 hours sitting around watch why don't
you just lie in line and then I watched
it will give us who wants to watch it
twice when Lucifer gift is make her
happy know what's going on I'm your
buddy support then you could also act
like you're the smartest guy on earth
until I think it's gonna happen before
pirates can I get selfish for a minute
Mike [ __ ] hour on Netflix I got a
Netflix on hours you wanna know you got
time to watch underworld I've seen every
movie you're in jail for [ __ ]
god forbid the boss found out he coming
to work together black eyes [ __ ] with an
arm sling like Luca from [ __ ] the
chick upstairs I have a new nickname
every show it's non Smosh it's not
smooth [ __ ] smoosh smoosh see what I got
a deal next I just got do like cubist
I'm gonna take two guys to kidnap me get
two of those black pirate one the world
I got the Santa Monica he's a pirate - I
don't know types of pipe I wanted to see
Gabe on narcos but there was a
documentary
the Spanish missions in California in
the 1400 a your hands behind you I can
show you into the mouth of a [ __ ]
hammer and say the next time you [ __ ]
up this is your [ __ ] job I learned a
long time ago Lee don't fall just lie
just oh yeah I haven't seen it yet
I don't know whatever we don't know let
me tell you story about say how bad that
is
let me tell you why I'm busting his
balls
right I have a very very very maybe a
very dear friend and he grew up with a
very very very dear friend and they
stayed friends for 30 years and one
night these two guys went to play golf
or some [ __ ] where they had to hang out
together and they got bored and they
went to a movie and the next day they
woke up and the one guy told my friend
who you can't say something like this to
him oh no he said to me a favor no no he
didn't say nothing till I guess they
went home and the two wives got together
and the movie came up
and she goes the movie was great my
husband went to see it yeah with your
husband
and she goes he would never do something
like that I thought that I'd ever ever
do something like that go see a movie
like that without me he musta lied to me
so she went oh [ __ ] and he denied it
oh and now today Chuck two childhood
friends don't talk because of that one
thing cause of that luck Jesus Christ
what a good movie 15 yeah least every
time I talk to one I go really good Wow
they blame your job the wife looked at
the other wife and said he knows some
damn damn that's how bad it got that's
how it starts with this [ __ ] little
thing here right here yeah it's not when
she told me I couldn't watch it why the
was she [ __ ] took in the corner grabs
you by the club and pointed at you
just don't ask me he was I swear to god
that's a true story and they still don't
talk after all to this day over they get
divorced or something like what no no I
bet the wife said you can never tell but
the one wife okay yeah I never talked to
him about Jesus and dudes listen like oh
well I guess I've shown you a [ __ ]
movie over a movie yeah well who gives a
[ __ ] who cares
just watch it again just go watch it
with him again
if something's good yeah I watch if I
watch it four times
yes i watch the all please sing the
lyrics I wanna you sit there we might
watch that Parks and Rec over and over
talk with your girlfriend yes you do yes
you do you were watching a couple weeks
ago when I call that's a reason why
don't tell me you were like wanna go
yes you did no please please no please
the boss here's one show it's the boss's
show you know the millions of other
people that is this that show talk about
the softest [ __ ] you know what I like
man oh my god
yeah dude I just I don't know man but
that's how I'm saying we like Goodfellas
I'll watch 40 times I watch those movies
Raging Bull do I want to rage I would
rather watch something that's
spectacular
right 40 times is something new that
came out that's garbage the exact I
won't even waste my [ __ ] time yeah I
wouldn't even if it's animates me
[ __ ] oh I won't even watch it I'd
rather watch something that I'm gonna
get a value out of them an emotion out
of yeah then I'm gonna learn an acting
move out of you know listen man let's be
honest I watched The Godfather
80 time oh man and every time I watch it
you learn something new I learn
something new every luckily I'm a line a
mannerism something Michael said
something Michael so I can't imagine
when I see a great Pete like this [ __ ]
that you thought was great like Miami
Vice the TV show yeah you put Miami Vice
on you like was the gun the [ __ ] gun
I'm gonna shoot myself like I really
watch this [ __ ] like the first two
seasons were very intrigued they were
grave the first two seasons after that
it was like one episode per season was
brilliant yeah everything else was
garbage I watched those over and over to
learn something to learn somebody
directing to to look at the editing
which I don't know about but I know when
something's clunky you ever watch
something you're like Jesus this is
[ __ ] monkey get the [ __ ] out of here
I never really got sold on the moving
cameras yet the new star it's that it's
very that's very rare when it works it's
sometimes it's okay but it's really hate
that move around yeah oh yeah and I got
like me would enjoy the rawness of it
right they're just doing it now to be
cute yeah even wrong right they're doing
it now just to be cute right like that
yeah yeah like like imagine the one that
it's just a good fella's for example the
the what's so funny about me seen like
that was perfect we're just at
stationary let's just hang on this dude
the whole time you know what I mean the
cameras just in one [ __ ] place right
on Joe Pesci it cuts once to see Ray
Liotta but then it's just you know it
works way back that's way more intense
than had it been [ __ ] you know
jerking around the whole table you know
no it's way better that scene is way
more intense just by just you just hang
on it you know like you just watch him
get angry you just watch him slowly get
and you're like whoa is this guy for
real or not like that that's why it's
one of the best scenes ever you know I
watched like I haven't lots of Sopranos
now for about a year I tried to watch on
about three months ago on oh my goood I
can't watch this
really yeah it's got to be like another
eight months and then I'll start from
scratch and I'll [ __ ] drool as I'm
watching right right right right Ronald
Reuel again Afeni ISM lunchroom at the
[ __ ] you know it's funny because
there was a thing two days ago that
that's it with Columbus Day yeah no more
Columbus days in California is a
nationwide I like indica yeah got a
bunch of Indians with arrows it's
[ __ ] tremendous Mexicans are pissed
on the other side they wanted the corn
and I'm saying they want to show up with
the corn but the Indians are indigenous
may know according to one thought so
that's already a beef that's a complete
different right these Indians of these
Mexicans on the Californians on
hard-edged you know I'm saying the
[ __ ] Indians are like we were the
original dream is what Indians like the
original dream and you guys came and
took the [ __ ] label if they could be
like hey you white [ __ ] with
the first dream yeah this is all a bit
crazy and he said that is something that
listen whatever Columbus beat up in the
end what he ended up just leave a [ __ ]
[ __ ] though now you want to sit not
these white people these care leaders
they don't want Columbus cuz he killed
it listen
Columbus destroyed Cuba did he really I
didn't know that was
think he went first uh yeah we did those
[ __ ] savages once there he destroyed
the guy's name was hot wait h ay tu e y
one of the best Malta's is El Sol and I
play the best boy I'm a lightweight type
of doing his [ __ ] so he [ __ ] went and
killed all those Indians first then he
came a P or its vice versa
I don't you know hey listen I got a B in
[ __ ] history what why he went to Cuba
first or second he destroyed a bunch of
things but listen bro we were ray you
already [ __ ] up and in the first grade
you told us he discovered America and
I'm not even Italian I'm sticking up for
the guy because it's too late you [ __ ]
up you didn't do the background check
what are you gonna come up with ten
years that Lincoln was really a pimp
black holes he was if you turn this
decision that means that every six weeks
so yeah I uncover some whoa what about
George Washington come on he was getting
this dick size you got slaves out of
here yeah yeah it's [ __ ] crazy
yeah so this is what this is gonna start
I don't understand these people look at
every way to Luther King oh yes you know
this ten white dudes [ __ ] doing a
background check to King right now and
say he didn't really hit it really March
he had those gel soles and [ __ ] he was
jealous he wasn't that's why you can't
overturn these type of [ __ ] right good
that I got president what are you gonna
do about the fourth of July when they
realize that the 4th of July they burned
25 black dudes right and three Mexican
[ __ ] what are you doing I turn that
to the fifth of July this is [ __ ]
stop this is my totally last week who
has will change Hanukkah what we gotta
change the Jew holiday I don't think so
yes I did I told you that what's the
other one yarmulke Passover Yom Kippur
is this week of next week what's that
I'm probably Yom Kippur that's why
there's one yeah okay that's what it
just start straight you [ __ ] New
Year's because I
you guys you show up in you show up
there right right right who show up here
not look at look at the [ __ ] the
Catholics the Catholics throwing the
25th we go off the real calendar but
then we go from July and then we go
March to April to [ __ ] six week so we
dominate some you guys take two weeks
here do we say cut it out
yeah just die [ __ ] that's it I'm at
Walt and go straight to the right till
New Year's and compete with the [ __ ]
Catholics I bet I pigeon Utley we're
just gonna bringing up at the next view
did in 10 years money it's just all
gonna be Special Olympians they're gonna
get rid of all the presidents it's just
it's just gonna be some kid who won the
three-legged race
like we got no dirt on this guy
we have no dirt on this guy we cannot
dig up anything I was a kid there was a
kid not Bergen I grew up where the I
name he was one of those kids that he
got stuck to his mother's [ __ ] so they
had to use it one of those four was his
name Vinny wood they used to call is so
they called the boy on the street he was
a little bit of Atari and he was okay he
had a little jewel to him and [ __ ] so
you wanted to be a flyer man that was
just a home environment I want to be
fine I love the environment so they
wouldn't make him a vine fireman so they
made of a volunteer fireman like a
shield just like to give my colonies
like a witch's so it could hit the head
with a brick it would hurt him so he
sued the talent not Bergen because they
wouldn't make him he got his funding
aroma well he sued to tell cuz they
wouldn't make him a fireman because they
couldn't find an homage to fit his head
so Vinnie warhead said [ __ ] if they gave
a little money to go away hey Devon the
Michael Jackson
like 25 but to get to get a bicycle and
a dog okay I swear to my mother's grave
takes to yoga dream so he was a
volunteer fireman they thought he would
forget all about right he was showing
about the fire on the on the trucks you
don't know he was just show up like a
truck with lights on and then after a
year after a year he started lighting
his own fires
oh no and he would call the fire
department
hey guy should be a fireman as little
which had on he Allen was from a which
had on a better fireman to you guys I
got here before you and I don't even
have a house and I wouldn't speak I
think he killed himself and pull the
vinny warhead himself I think put him on
were you two over Vinny what okay put
him on the knee warhead on the MB New
Jersey here go - yum yum donuts here's
three warheads here's three warheads
[Laughter]
when I was in stress factory one time it
was a Thursday night like the whole
bleep oh yeah yeah and I got high I was
just chucking stuff out man yeah
Thursday's can sometimes be the best
nights of the week you ever notice that
listen to me brah we're saying something
about 60 of my friends with it and they
were on this side and I swear to God
you know I don't give a [ __ ] what
neighborhood you're from you know yeah
every neighborhood has one [ __ ] and
right there that name came up and I go
to the North Bergen guys ago in North
Bergen we have many warheads and just
the name war had made them all fall out
I had forgotten all about it
listen I haven't thought about many wars
since I left high school right
hey he sued the TV helmet and he started
like this old fire and telling the fire
department they were slipping and [ __ ]
it's like those Tribble runs you see all
that [ __ ] here do you ever did you ever
do like you ever did you avoid the
triple runs of ddrum triple runs is how
you learn how did you come by my world
trip was comedy 101 because you learn
everything all in one day insurance yes
you know how to do comedy about Mormons
you learn how to stretch on $50 for
weight yeah four nights of you have $10
to live outside you learn how to prepare
your car man long ride in that amazing
like I never it was about how I became
an expert on my car just doing trouble
runs I was like oh okay this yeah you
know you don't have to be a mechanic
nope you learn all these I got a
fucked-up radiator so I could either
drop the 300 for the radiator right I'll
put that bottle of pellets in it every
time I started I had a box of pellets of
like you understand me I seemed
Stanhope's travel car yeah yeah stick
across the backseat and he hung his
clothes on there yeah when I went back
to Boulder I did the same thing a weekly
[ __ ] yeah so I had a four seat car with
the [ __ ] curtain yeah act of the
clothing and you got the whole week with
a fellow back there
I had [ __ ] a blanket back there I had
a on one side I had like some something
out like every part of the car was you
served the purpose it served a purpose
it was the first time my life that I
learned every part of a car is utilized
that side door this door pocket the
thing that you pull in the middle of the
backseat and stay and into the back yeah
just in case I was sleep in the trunk
and I can get back into my car cuz you
got a hick a [ __ ] like that when you're
on a [ __ ] bus why'd you sleep in the
trunk maybe there's a rapist yeah I got
a big dykon-- you know i don't know you
just think about these things I remember
a road comic one time told me when I was
doing one of the tribal runs he said cuz
one that had to stop and just sleep out
in the middle of nowhere
yeah yeah and because he does go to he
goes go to Toys R Us get a toy gun that
looks and just put it
and put wear a hoodie and just put it in
the thing so people think you're packing
so they don't [ __ ] with you like I've
learned you learnt all those crazy
tricks just to how not to get robbed you
know what I mean like when you sleep on
my not to get robbed I love to have
people come up to you and ask you just
sucked it right right right
oh god it tastes all those truck
stations I call those trucks that
there's those truck stops where you pull
out and it's chase trucks go trucks go
this way and car cars go that there's
more pimps than Vegas what is there I
took the truck route yeah you know I was
high I've done that too I've been
driving 11 hours you know Kelly it gets
[ __ ] long and I went that way and
there was a spot my party man within
three minutes he disappeared like this
dirty white chick yes yes did she
disappear then like a black guy came by
those are all prostitutes they're just
looking to see what you like and they
have showers in there like yeah oh those
are the ones where there's just a
bathroom a soda machine what peanuts
because Leon on the truck lanes most of
those 18 wheelers it's like a moving
studio apartment so they just do all
their business in the truck they don't
even have to go into the showers they
can you know the prostitutes they just
hop into the truck with them you know
they just do their business in the truck
and then that's it like I've I've talked
to so many truck drivers doing the road
like and listen to them to they'll give
you tips you know what I mean like they
know all that like just the creepy [ __ ]
it's fascinating man it's like a whole
nother underworld I don't know I'd never
spoken almost triple what was the guy
that Texas CW Kenzie double you can yeah
yeah Dana and Doug McGraw tomorrow
Nebraska out of all those people I don't
think I ever I went back to for me to
survive I had to go back to how I acted
in New Jersey like what the [ __ ] are you
looking at I do eat Ali yeah you didn't
[ __ ] with people no strange no way I
didn't [ __ ] with people at bus stations
like Center so you look straight ahead
and I'm my
my own business I didn't know nothing
remember taking greyhounds to gigs and
like and you would have to sit there and
like dude cuz Greyhound stations are
like free-for-alls
it ends a [ __ ] joke you'll see a
knife fight I'm yield you see and you
just have to pretend you didn't see
anything you just like keep your mouth
shut mind your own business and let it
happen
and just walk onto the bus when it's
time like it is [ __ ] insane those
places they're my favorite I never took
a Greyhound bus in my [ __ ] life I
moved to Los Angeles and there was a
club nope a so called the comic strip
yes and he would call you the Monday
that's the Monday afternoon before the
Tuesday show at 8:00 hey can he make it
and ask you if you wanted a week there
now any [ __ ] knows and he would
pay you 300 two feet to MC yeah which is
not bad and see money back to her ticket
was 180 yeah
so you made 120 all for [ __ ] from
Tuesday through Saturday you [ __ ]
crazy yeah you had to take the bus so I
used to take the bus and left here
Monday night it had 11 o'clock at night
and there was the Express and it got you
into El Paso whatever I say yeah yeah
that's all it takes just 13 hours that's
it the Express they don't do they cuz
like most greyhounds will stop at our
little town Expressway yeah brutal
because the midway point is like 6:30 in
the morning yeah see you got on the bus
at 11:00 by the tack of time it took off
with 11:30 midway point is six limite so
I think you could sleep you can't sleep
on the [ __ ] bus did you think of that
well you probably fall asleep like an
hour before you start well before you
stop they're not smooth right you eat
the worst food ever [ __ ] bus station
restaurant is Christ well now they have
AC did they have AC back that is how
they see but the problem is the food
it's still garbage like it's still
brutal no that shit's brutal that shit's
brutal and then you got tell Passover
there on the way back you did it would
blow like I would take a little bit of
long bang with me I'm gonna for that
first time some guy gave me a gram of
coke and I can held on to it to bring
him back that way yeah he was
and I [ __ ] him get up get on them when I
get on the bus I sit in the back to
feature actors in the back I think I
featured the first time right and the
headline I was in the back he was some
black dude I think he's still around and
i sat by myself he was clean and sober
he took a bus - he took the bus so he
got me to get up passed his bar probably
called him them day before also Rajah
Paul Roger Bart called Roger Paul and
the guy called me memories I took a
Lester done when I was supposed to just
for my first weekend yeah that's when
they wept iguana from Taco Cabana yep
and then Biondo with people would just
knock on your door hiya hey there's the
comedy condo yeah party and your life
it was crazy crazy that would never
happen man I was 30 minutes I was
already joined and I had a 13 [ __ ]
hour but this coke was on fire it was
still glass cold it was glass like the
way it was in the eighties I was gonna
save her that [ __ ] and man I couldn't do
it do a little bumps and finally they
pull over immigration stop along with
the dogs to see if you had coke and I
took that home one [ __ ] and by the time
they got back to me I had my teacher
just hit this wedding up a storm with a
look on my face I was guilty as [ __ ]
even the dog is looking at me like I
know you I know you [ __ ] bark well I
know you did
I was flopped up I did that whole
package in one line I sweat for like
four I was DRAM all the way the Tempe I
sweat like horrible bus runs yeah Trevor
runs were nightmares man I used to
develop that and then from there I would
do I would take the bus to Dallas to do
which one no to connect the Dallas and I
take the expressed in New York
oh no days Dallas to New York was like
110 maybe Oh less the bus it was 49 Wow
yeah that's why because I know you get a
gram of coke for 35 hours yeah sorry I'd
say what do I want to do I want to
[ __ ] fly there and only get one gram
I could take the bus to do three grams
I'll take the bus and do three grams my
[ __ ] dude forget it and I would take the
bus to Port Authority yeah get off call
my friend Rago or lubes they'd pick me
up we go right to the man's house we'd
pick up a package I'm all over the
George Washington Bridge I'd stay there
for a couple days I figured raspy I
feature Rascals down the shore yeah and
then from there we go to Myrtle Beach
yeah and then for Myrtle Beach I would
go to [ __ ] in Jacksonville not only what
the Jacksonville one time to the hotel
with the Friday night all you can write
new [ __ ] bleep where's that what was
the Rodger Paul room in Poughkeepsie was
that bananas bananas at the kids that
was when I was in the hotel right was in
a hotel yeah yeah and they've always put
you up but they put you up downstairs
yes Lee yes let me tell you something
was that what the room was for why was
that room in the basement I love cold
weather me too I love the cult you have
no idea when it was in that basement
hotel room rudl not a Saturday morning
at 9:00 then you got to get up to pee
your fries had no and the heat was on
til [ __ ] 90 yeah and you're still
blowing smoke yeah how cold it was up
there
[ __ ] you let me tell you what there was
we you walk downstairs and they had the
worst hotel Dinah no no Jackson that was
Jackson Upstate Peter babe these people
did you a favor you should have hung out
there they gave you 25% off to eat
yeah if you were a comedian yep it was
25% closer to your debt and then the
only thing you had was 30 yards there
was next to a gas station that was it
that was your pickup see yeah that was
it if you didn't have a car
oh that was your weekend you were you
were [ __ ] didn't even have a car and
there was no [ __ ] buffets in those
days like you woke up in the morning no
you went downstairs and you gave him
1195 and you got a little bit of rice
krispies you got some oatmeal three
pieces of bacon you got the sausage I
remember when that breakfast used to be
good the last couple places that I've
gone and they've been like chained Hotel
some of them that have had like the free
breakfast in the morning like you can't
even eat let if the eggs are like I had
one place that was taking hard-boiled
eggs and just chopping them up and
building something real quick and these
are the people who don't know for people
who travel a lot is not meant for you
get to go downstairs and eat like a
[ __ ] King if you go to a hotel and
again this is no offense to nobody and
no nationalities I'm just telling you
how it is okay if you go to a hotel and
you smell basil and what's another [ __ ]
curry curry I'm not assuming any
nationality involved those are [ __ ]
powdered eggs like a [ __ ] I
don't want you to go downstairs and feed
your [ __ ] kids those eggs like this
they're like there's never okay that
breakfast at the hotel is no hold you
over you could go to a civilized
organization get a real meal and get a
real meal you got right there so few
people travel no other breakfast gave me
my hemorrhoid came back it's just meant
to get you to the next meal up the
corner yep so if you go to Jersey you're
not going to Jersey
things at the hotel I'm white I don't
have you going downstairs it's seven
when you wake up right after you eat
your wife's [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and
maybe some rice krispies and you bring
them up to your room you don't you don't
never sit parity no that's you need to
make unless it's New Jersey in New York
or Boston
oh yeah bagels are for new bagels bagels
ustym incubators those bagels are as
they say in the movies for gazing after
making all right stick to the [ __ ]
Cheerios [ __ ] the Special K that's a
you know I'll tell you what those
powdered eggs I won't touch but if I see
a hard-boiled egg listen if it buys me
an hour and I don't get carsick I take
two pieces of white bread I Britian the
toaster I killed that [ __ ]
bread with that maggoty butter and I
take that [ __ ] hard-boiled egg and I
cut it into slices like a little [ __ ]
savage you eat that with a bowl of
Cheerios nothing bad could happen to you
yeah remember one thing you can either
cows [ __ ] hey the moldy Cheerios and
you balanced out for the day
if you're looking at for a yin to your
yang interior always balances yeah
what's the number one selling Cheerios
honey not no honey nut is what you
[ __ ] regular ones are in the Cheerios
you eat the regular cheerios and it
lowers your cholesterol I didn't know
that well I mean what pressure honey I
did that's what oats does to you
okay naturally lowers it it's like oh
you know I don't want you to go eat 22
slices of bacon [ __ ] half a cow and
these are bowl of Cheerios they come to
me and say Joey I got a heart attack no
no no no no no I'm talking about if you
eat a [ __ ] decent breakfast every day
like oatmeal yeah and then see oatmeal
supposedly suck some out of your
bloodstream
cholesterol yeah out of your bloodstream
you know it's good worry about [ __ ] yeah
I heard sandal meal why would you you
like hummus well I'm surprisingly the
hummus for breakfast
I have but do you ever eat Cheerios for
breakfast yeah milk just cheerios nope
ah no sugar no ice cream no [ __ ] hey
Wonder Woman I have ice cream for
breakfast Lee nothing that you do
surprise goes to the Korean language can
anyone pull up I wish I had the episode
with them orange is the new black
justice just to see I don't know I'm
yeah I don't know eat a lot of cereal
for breakfast it could be good moments
man I love cereal there's no [ __ ] I'm
just oh there's your boy of eighteen oh
wow
look at that look at that eating cereal
I see it yeah that's crazy
look I thought that was a hat oh that's
what I had the jew-fro were so far away
that's crazy
when did you get that just now someone
just sent it to you yeah no I just
[ __ ] it with his bird of happiness and
the CIA just dropped off for that blah
Blee I know you said on your phone I'm
asking if you've got it like now or have
you just if someone just randomly tested
on the podcast he's telling me now her
texting words have to be fly can use the
Bluebird of happiness right this
fluttered in
[Laughter]
nobody brightens my day likely nobody
he's he doesn't understand he thinks I
pay him for the pain for this company I
pay him for entertainment just to get
his in I'm starting thinking of starting
a business I got the idea from him and
he calls me to aggravate me every day
I'm gonna call people to brighten a day
I also provide that service if you want
somebody to call you aggravate you I got
the first 10% I'm the inspiration
inspiration be unemployed let me get a
[ __ ] paper table again today you all
right what happened go to my dentist
tomorrow he has a leadership that lays
no [ __ ] work yes it does my tongue
didn't bleed this is the one I'm gonna
go home to do I got a [ __ ] tube of
Krazy Glue no that's so toxic that
doesn't matter I swam in the Hudson okay
I ain't a [ __ ] heels hard woman that
my friend Mike caught alright Joey do
some crazy glue in your mouth they let
you lick for a quarter for [ __ ] ten
fifty let your finger in no way for a
hundred bucks then let you watch a movie
before that for a hundred bucks you get
some watching our ghost oh it's not a
documentary okay I have a suck the
[ __ ] black jig state off a [ __ ]
pig show you don't mean the younger I'd
well I was younger I would go to beef
shows I was still petrified a [ __ ] and
yeah sure you know how old you to sneak
in break it they didn't give a [ __ ]
listen if you ran by the big guy the
door he going you come back that's it
thank you an [ __ ] he wanted you to go
in there they want you to get tempted
ago the [ __ ] because yeah [ __ ] the
neighborhood is your set you're in for
life yeah you're alive you're in for
life
was their job in the 70s when you walked
up a th they he's up in 42nd Street
ah that was the fact that the [ __ ]
cigarette companies right they want for
it they want it over there passing out
cigarettes at the library we think
they're doing it for this stop kids were
smoking no because they want kids to
[ __ ] smoke cigarettes the same listen
I've told you guys I totally a thousand
times I went to grammar school with two
brothers one that was straight up and
the other one that was a little mo mo da
and every Monday they came they were in
the pilot program okay which meant that
you had a they had come from Q by the
young age okay there's none of being a
dreamer right they call them pilot
program
I remember here in pilot program yeah a
pilot program was you had to stay back
to you learn the language okay okay so
once you got the language it could have
been three years so by the time you got
to the seventh grade if you were driving
to school you were eligible for the
pilot program I'm not very good now if
you were driving to school or you had
kids you were here in therapy in the
seventh grade at McKinley I've been like
feeling insecure because in the seventh
grade there was like three or four kids
who sat in the back of my head hairy
legs and beards and the hair under their
armpits
you know because yeah because they're
right in front of me in gym class in gym
class you got a change of other guys and
I'd be there with my tighty whities with
that bozo hairdo on my dick we're just
the slides get filled in then you have
that two-year pause where the middle
hair grows you're bad that's it's
happened every guard yeah every man when
we're about 13 come here besides you're
like and you're like in nine months I'm
gonna be slinging you even time it quick
you say well if this if the if the from
the home plate to the outfield yeah that
that foul line
because that's what it's called from you
don't line your dick is the home plate
okay right the first thing that grows is
the following hair it grows all the way
up now gets bushy quick but it leaves a
gap in the middle and they have a row
gate right at the Bozo the Clown bozo to
count blow now in those days you had two
options second basins in a field this
[ __ ] [ __ ] up it looks like [ __ ]
Harvey in it there is not a tree there's
[ __ ] nothing there's nothing you're
[ __ ] sitting there every day
you're planning I'm [ __ ] your
babysitter what the hair won't grow
you're thinking about row game the organ
that works a little bit as you take
mascara I gotta put like a purple light
on in Led Zeppelin like why you putting
the purple light on cuz I'm putting out
legs up ten years half year so it was
that's how we talked about the pilot
program which you were saying with the
pilot program badly by the way how did
you know he had a head that's how I
[ __ ] knew bleep because if I was ten
and I had hair this guy was like 17 it
was like the dominican little league
team nobody showed up with fake birth
certificates these kids are all 12 these
are all that 12 year old Dominicans who
have full beards and like six three and
they're just almost didn't I see him on
the pit on the Padres like all the kids
in my school that were in the pilot
program I still no more Peter Jimenez
Luis Zaldivar
because Luis olive autism he just turned
56 last week so he was on Facebook yeah
happy birthday happy Michael is one of
my friends ice and the funny thing was
that he was 16 when I was 14 or
something like that right but they had
taken him out like the SEPA so all these
kids were either 16 or 17 and they were
still in the seventh grade and it was
scattered all around the North Bergen
school system where the other kids are
scared shitless of them was everybody
just terrified I don't know guys they
were okay it was like I remember like
three of them that we actually hung out
with that were gray eyes yeah but they
had like insecurities there was sixteen
hanging out with kids that were 13 right
you know how bad the game they were
always in the back of the graduation
practice if you looked at McKinley's
graduation pictures the background of
previous five years everybody in the
back at be human women pregnant [ __ ]
[ __ ] hilarious hilarious that's great
nobody remembers the pilot front then
they did away with it they just kill
Yeller and you [ __ ] if you're that
stupid drop out a job I totally haven't
know we can't help you
number two very much congratulations for
you oh thank you so much man tried to
get you on before the release it's okay
and we're looking schedules and whatnot
yeah and I meant to get you on and then
this guy cancelled this cowboy it's a
good time to have just isn't honor huh
plus I miss you it's weird be Cannell
old you haven't seen me live three
blocks away from each other home and we
know there was a time when we lived
three states apart we talked more yeah I
know I know talk more because I would
always go to El Paso when I'd request
him it was a bath man or somewhere else
then we and then we as soon as I go he'd
already have the Chinese restaurant
ready I knew where to go here we're
gonna go here he knew this he always do
and then I'm in the beam somewhere and
you showed up and took me to eat like
yeah yeah I work some way we're just
passing through out there and you picked
me up and took me to a [ __ ] restroom
[ __ ] like that those are the best days
dude it was cow we had so much fun we
used to go to a Chinese restaurant no
paso on the other side there on Friday
yeah oh you can eat yes and it was
[ __ ] god-awful
it was terrible sweet-and-sour it looked
like a [ __ ] bleed the place when you
walked outside a palace yeah rip clubs
yeah yeah it was well as things were it
was the size of a target you know what I
mean it literally was that big it was
this massive and they had the big golden
[ __ ] lions and Dragons outside and
all that stuff and you go and can't do
those noodles
I also remember - I felt so bad but
where we go we went we went shopping for
clothes and then I remember went and
bought like eight action figures at a
comic the best always I remember I was
leaving I was gonna drive back to Dallas
right and I was in the morning I was
gonna get up and go and you just said
where the [ __ ] you going and I was like
what and then just pointed the TV and it
was the history of Pink Floyd was on vh1
classic remember that we're both like oh
[ __ ] I'm not going anywhere
we stayed yeah that was a vast man that
was so much fun but you know thanks Ben
did you get here that the the CDA guy of
all those old blood psychedelic metal
bands yes that's good [ __ ] as I put it
in my car and when I [ __ ] traitor oh
that was what I was gonna get you again
I gotta get to you again it's they were
great though weren't they you know which
I sometimes it's good just to get a
surprise right sometimes it's good to
put something in your car we have
nothing to lose and you know you're
gonna get stuck on the 405 right and you
really got to make calls right it's so
much traffic you don't want to talk
you're in the HOV lanes driving by
yourself yeah you got to pay attention
to see that motorcycle cop is coming
over really
yeah cuz that 405 I got on the HOV
[ __ ] well I'm not alone or the bus
with eleven midgets yeah I gotta be a
chosen what are the odds they're really
gonna bust all they'll catch you you
think yeah oh man I do have see them bus
people you this time where you got to do
it you don't do it by the law you do it
if you're gonna do it listen it's gonna
be a 500-mile ticket no matter how you
look at it right right so I do was [ __ ]
gets hairy BAM I shoot over the whole
time of my mom eyes in that rearview
mirror feds are watching first like Ray
Liotta looking for the helicopter yeah I
see a motorcycle and he's kind of weird
yeah I'll pop the [ __ ] out it's right
against mine right 100 yards away unless
he's [ __ ] Johnny eyeballs no way well
he was a sniper yeah and he ain't all
his carrots you know I always pay
attention number two I got the baby seat
in the back oh that helps that already
tricks people that already tricks people
so I've already had them drive by me
going Jesus Joseph please Lord please
Lord right number two I don't take
advantage of right just every time we go
to the airport
fair enough Hey hi I paid my tax dollars
to the five per a look at your plane
ticket you're not all these exactly even
look at all these phone company
commercials that come on and go what am
i paying for this what am I paying for
the right look at your [ __ ] plane
ticket yeah you pay for [ __ ]
Charlie's roller skates at the Blind
Side you pay for [ __ ] a thousand
things and again but gently it's only a
dollar 18 yeah but from how many [ __ ]
subscribers how many plane tickets do
they sell a day oh God Oh astronomical
because like we said there's never been
an empty flight I've you know Navy yeah
I've never been on a flight that was it
completely packed nine times out of ten
this flights completely full can you
please give us any of your large bags
we'll chill we'll check it to your final
destination and it's like how they
running out of space if everybody can
only put one up in the top there should
be room for ever no no there's nothing
there's no because people have gotten in
and I don't blame people but then again
I do believe yeah okay you again we're
talking about saving every time if every
time
you fly to go home to see your
grandmother was dying of cancer you pay
$50 for your luggage and you go home
once a month that's $600 a year you're
paying for your luggage if you spend
half of that on your grandmother and
bought her flowers this guy's is hey how
you have to think when you're making
$60,000 or below right and you get
putting a bad situation in your life oh
yeah man and there comes a time where
you're gonna get put in a bad situation
in your life and those [ __ ] plane
people with thieves god they're thieves
because okay let's pretend you have a
death of the family
listen it costs you more they charge you
half of a full flight fare at fit and at
the end of the day you're paying more
than with a touch on the computer yeah
you're paying more than 1000 the
computer either wife is you gotta go
home and act like a [ __ ] fool yeah
tap the the funeral director on the and
get a copy of the [ __ ]
that's certificate and send it to these
[ __ ] moves yeah and that's what you
want to do if sends an idea of a dirt
certificate right of somebody dead no
computer pool for a thousand people to
[ __ ] look at and then send to the
Russian one today you're gonna call that
your grandmother's alive and kick'n
happen [ __ ] the Bronx and you can't
believe it you knock on the door that's
a Russian to do with a [ __ ] afro
because they stole your identity via
American that time when your grandmother
died all right they got a perfect
[ __ ] pigeon now isn't that one I
don't even have to go into the archives
to see who died to match their age in
the old days you got to go into a
[ __ ] horrible and see what kids died
that year and match it to yours
it's a [ __ ] I'm Harry angel from
angel heart you [ __ ] you gotta walk
around with a dog tag it's [ __ ] crazy
so what do people do you blame them do I
blame Johnny Charlie for trying to save
50 [ __ ] bucks someone by bring a
Beatles and jolly Charlie has to live
like a [ __ ] yam to those poor
bastards that means you gotta that means
you got a pack on three ounces of
toothpaste right you can only bring one
tampon
because God ride and you can only bring
one pair of socks so they go through
your [ __ ] that eliminates marijuana
maybe a vapor pen
eliminate all that [ __ ] yeah but you get
true you're gonna off the plane and you
go right to your [ __ ] old book yeah I
can't I can't be mad at you for doing
that right right right yeah that's true
it's true
like I uh but it is interesting like how
much money you know we talk like that
don't like they charge you for it's a
shittiest Wi-Fi on earth and it's like
eight dollars for the you're on the
plane for an hour like why am I gonna
spend eight dollars just so I can check
to emails you know why would it but
people do it because they get business
people who've is my thing yeah yeah I'm
like [ __ ] I'll wait till I land you
know I'll wait there's nothing I can do
open a plane anyway you know what I mean
so I'll wait till I land and then I'll
just check all the emails at once you
know like what what could I do up in a
you know I was paying for the Wi-Fi for
about a year
yeah I would go up and get go go
whatever sure yep go go take my money
but you know what for what I was doing
guys
it was the perfect deal it was ninety
five four three hours I'm on this plane
for [ __ ] five and a half let's kick
it right oh yeah oh yeah an iPod that's
got Grand Funk Railroad you're good like
I'm good oh I got the cars on there
I got Zeppelin on there I got everything
that you would not it that at times you
look at it your house and be selfish
with your time yeah I really pretend
there's two but I just don't have the
time right all right I'm on a plane
headed to New York but time I ate six of
these stars a vapor pen I got a xanax
I'm a fire jacket understand me I'm
living like a doctor they gave me a
mojito when you fly JetBlue meant to
give you a mismo yeah baby
what and then you tell lady bring me
another one you hope she's black and you
tell her that you'll be she's blocking
your tell listen you look at the
straightening iron you'll be chasing
after this flight I'm gonna go
take Beyonce he's posted down it's you
baby it's nothin but you I don't give a
[ __ ] if she looks like a meal you tell
her that it's all over the rest of the
flight everything everything's [ __ ]
on me on you live in like Benny without
the jet [ __ ] yeah I've had tremendous
times on those flights man yeah that's
fine I definitely do I just load up
music I get I I don't say two words now
I sat next to Charles broccoli that's
the first time I said anything that
anybody ears was about a year ago wow he
just happened to get on the end yeah
right next to me good dude but I didn't
say done for about an hour right right
and then he said something to me how you
doing good man like a brought was a fan
of the sexes I went to school down there
love julius erving was my idol we talked
about julius talked about him being and
he was it he hasn't said i kept it light
with him yeah but I was on a roll for a
while
he has my favorite sports Cordover you
read the book about the dream team says
you know when they put together your and
for the Olympics right and at the
opening of the book the author he wrote
here over Sports Illustrated he was the
only guy who got to follow him right so
he talks about like how competitive
Jordan was how you [ __ ] like dude
they were playing ping-pong in the
Olympic room and Christian Laettner beat
Jordan and ping-pong and Jordan like
flip the table and through the padlet
he's ready to kill him because he lost
it [ __ ] ping-pong too late or he
didn't like losing and they but Barkley
had the best quote who it was it just it
just it was before the US was gonna play
Angola in the Olympic Games and Barkley
said I don't know nothing about Angola
but they're in some trouble no we won by
like 60 watch those games you know why
you play these people over saying they
think they're playing Division one junk
anonymous [ __ ] light them up for 40 when
I was a kid right I went to McKinley and
they broke up the town into seven teams
so uptown was Robin Fulton
okay can and Anna hell client from
Guttenberg but they had Horace Mann a
and Horace Mann beat so that made up for
four teams uptown nice so Horace Mann a
was eighth grade service Bambi was
seventh grade okay
and they always got beat up by everybody
downtown it was McKinley Lincoln
Franklin and Kennedy okay the greatest
basketball players in that town always
came from Kennedy School like the one
guy who led the Kallie Leeds account
[ __ ] with the seat hall led the nation
in scoring a CNA year have a seat hall
we kicked his shoe he was just six foot
water tire and he took they took him two
years to do the fall for being at the
high school Tommy Heinsohn being there
washers that's whose record he broke
time so he was there one night damn I
saw a [ __ ] Digger Phelps at hash ways
when they were recruiting him they're
recruiting him deep they brought all the
big guns to get this can show this
Kennedy School this Kennedy School had a
coach named mr. Ruger okay and why this
is eighth grade coaching okay guys this
is 1975 okay I'm in the seventh grade
I'm playing McKinley school I'm not I'm
not starting I'm not doing anything I
just went to the practices to get beat
up
mm-hm that's back when the Knicks were
great today weren't they back then I
have no [ __ ] idea
I was I was listening to I don't even
know you know you care about sports yeah
I did but I had
memory fright right I'll I'm sitting in
this [ __ ] classroom and the coaches
were just regular guys like it was like
it would be like guys for the projects
right I got a city job burger they paid
him for eight weeks to coach we had a
guy that would just come a slam dunk the
whole time just slam dunk the seventh
rate he was terrible then we had
somebody else who quit and then we had a
guy who hated [ __ ] he was a Nazi oh this
is a two-story okay so my eighth grade
year I worked my ass off was he good at
basketball yes and what happened was the
[ __ ] guy who was crazy
I had this guy's in the system but not
well he did not see the mats he would
always say [ __ ] and [ __ ] can all this
[ __ ] right but he would say just like
think the guy who lied him home to tame
it down you guys know this I have a joke
that one that I thought about this I'm
like 4:00 in the morning came to my mind
i'ma drop some heavy knowledge on you
[ __ ] even though my niece is in
the room she's heard all the stories she
hasn't heard this one she's had now this
is the niece that in 1984 when she was a
baby my uncle a brother Mahalo uncle
used to hide his coke under her crib
while she was sleeping I have to tiptoe
into our room pick her up and take the
coke up your stairs take a chunk out and
put it back like I think a fee you
weren't gonna be a bear she's is they're
holding babies with my backbone for
years
and she never ratted me out you know I'm
saying she's solid you learnt how to
hold the baby to get that coat no I'm a
rocker to see like that no it was a crib
and it had like a mattress but under the
mattress was a a piece of reinforced
wood okay which meant it was particle
wood glued together it was heavy but not
really yeah the coke was hidden in
between that and the springs there's
like that spider-man spring and it was a
big [ __ ] Manila thing so I would have
to pick up the thing
while she was sleeping and take the coke
going on stairs take a chunk out and put
it back her uncle used to work at a
baker with this doodler OC it was a
party well they were supposed to be up
there baking all night they'd be snoring
that bake and nobody was eating this
went on for years it was it was calling
them and they made the best strawberry
shortcake ah ha ha so every Sunday when
you woke up Stevie would bring home a
strawberry shortcake he was solid he was
devoted you understand me [ __ ]
tremendous great what we talking about
we were talking about ok but not good
not see so yeah Taryn ok so we'll talk
about Rugal later and why these good
basketball players don't let me forget
why they came out of Kennedy School ok
but this lot C takes over the [ __ ]
basketball system we're [ __ ]
tremendous - [ __ ] I got left back you
lose reps during the warm-up I got left
back in the seventh grade you don't need
him to bring me back was to get really
good at Baskin yeah yeah I was in love
with this girl I used to let me [ __ ]
what's that when you drive huh yeah
remember how amazing that was
dry-humping promise who's gonna give it
to me baby
right she wanted a she reneged like more
but I couldn't take it no more she broke
my heart so I got left back but anyway
that's a complete different story I'm at
this [ __ ] seventh grade the second
time and this is how I Unseld in love by
playing bascomb yeah and dog I remember
one day going up to my courts and it had
just snowed in North Bergen yeah and a
bunch of guys were coming down to play
like good guys in 38th Street Court went
up so the other team didn't know this
[ __ ] they're running uphill trying to
shoot we're blocking this [ __ ] and on
the way down our room was two inches low
you're Duncan's oh I couldn't dunk but I
can hold on to the recommend this pumps
is [ __ ] anyway we put together this
badass [ __ ] basketball team comin up
napkin they're my
I'm over here bleeding to death he put
together tremendous basketball team
right
ah this is not good
it's in my teeth
alright so that summer you know I'm
black I'm a blossoming young man my
handsome blood red spot over there
I'm a handsome [ __ ] dry-humping
little [ __ ] cute girl and you know
you know I'm a gentleman
I was scared then I was brokenhearted
still from the other girl who broke my
heart that first heartache is a worry
about that first heartache is the one I
didn't want my heart to be broken again
I played it very safe first cut is very
safe I played it very safe and you know
I cook around me you know when I say
take you out with we walked around the
corner told each other jokes that was a
day then I said man and I kissed it
cheek and this woman like two times when
you're in seventh grade that's a great
day I don't know what's going on I'm
playing basketball I want to be the next
[ __ ] michael call another Jersey City
New Jersey and whatnot to played North
Carolina and started his freshman year
oh sure yes he double a finals and went
off in the semi-finals against when
Ganju second UNLV oh wow 31 points that
[ __ ] little white boy out of Jersey City
nice what the brothers how to [ __ ]
play a game that's badass and then they
wrote an article bottom because he was
raised by a single white chick who was a
waitress so Sport magazine wrote an
article about how tough this Irish woman
was to raise this [ __ ] kid and he got
a scholarship was [ __ ] baller to
Hudson Catholic with this guy named John
spin Arkell he's an analyst Mouse I
spoke about this before
anyway I date this girl two times
you know he's cute I'm cute but she went
to Holy Rosary Academy number one and
number two she was like a year or two
older look at you dude okay we talked on
the phone you know she had strict
parents that watched her and [ __ ] so now
we're practicing on the street we got
this coach his name was Peter where we
were impressed with Peter Webb because
he was 6 foot 1 he could [ __ ] slam it
and in those days if you could slam you
all right with you know saying that you
can slam that's pretty badass
you're all right with me ok so [ __ ]
he slam and he takes the coaching job he
quits after three games his assistant
was the Nazi on Facebook he's in the SS
I'm gonna release his name he's probably
still a Nazi he is magic he was at the
Charlottesville rally with the door he
shows up and I don't know my team was
filled with array of characters my
starting team was in those days was
chuckling brain me Louie hey man there's
aka Louie damn [ __ ] so you didn't like
me Oh Louie that's half the team years
right now yeah that was the other
[ __ ] two guys Jesus Christ David rhew
has transferred to Kennedy so they
called him Benedict Arnold yeah so we
had two other guys in Jesus Christ
yes I came who they are my man we're a
good team we went four and three bad
[ __ ] he came on after that like all
these guys came on before the season
started dad we got here okay the Nazi
came on to prepare us with two weeks
left to go now guess what yes good
precision guess what well so the Nazi
comes down at the code and he's
everything's going okay he really
doesn't really know what's going on
by this point we're playing our own
[ __ ] game
well you know we we Wall Street guys we
play it every day together play for the
last two years together so we knew each
other this guy was just coming in he was
coming in to make his drill and she like
this so guess what happens guess who
that broad was that I was swapping spit
with his daughter his sister oh sorry
me and I start talking tighter in time
if she shows up at a practice one day
with the mother and they clap she not
seen up to was she oh no no she was
dateless Peck how does she I mean she
would date let's pick up and secrecy
girl you got a key pass to the future if
you want to finger bang a girl from you
sure you can't say dick you say is her
grandmother it will call you so we're
about to [ __ ] start the season okay
we're about to start the season
what about a week away from the start
the [ __ ] season and what the [ __ ] oh
my god the other forward was God rested
so Anthony Balsamo and on the forward
was Dominic specially out how God rested
oh I'm so oh [ __ ] yeah bro past bullpen
anyway that's a complete different story
why bring sadness into the rap and I'm
not gonna kill a chicken and do some
Santeria thematic [ __ ] like that for
this show baby night we decided to hook
up on our [ __ ] stairs one day she
lived right next to Lyon any fuel way
before your time Madison plank or
whatever that street is that passes
given that terrorists and liberty
whatever Street turns into McKinley
going straight up if I pass behind us
implant I go straight up anyway and when
we were kids there was a bunch of oil
tankers denims called Lyon that he feel
they delivered fuel T for your house
fuel that she shares in the winter they
were the first house next to Lyon that
he feel
young man we chitchat outside we did
this two three nights no getting nip in
the air you gotta have a little sweater
a little warm up a little bit
one night we stuck get a little closer
because now we gain trust we didn't go
out to like animals if we just went out
there to talk and the mother would come
out every ten minutes in check
you're right and their father will come
on everything okay and we'd be out there
giggling they go back in for three days
I played it like Johnny cool yeah but
then I had to go deep in the murky
waters the one night I might there we
start swapping spit I'm sayin things get
hot I squeeze a little teddy you know
saying everything's gettin we're
starting to breathe that he has to the
unzip of pants and she unzipped and I
put my hand down there he told to go
inside I just unzip my hand out of there
held on to it cuz you know I was gonna
say hey you gotta kill me for me that
this is that if I cut it off no I walked
home quick like a mother [ __ ] never
make 12 minutes to preserve the night
was pulled up never been the real baller
move just never the next day I went to
practice the Nazi quit not the word from
[ __ ] Rommel it's over
so why was that so why did that school
at the other school have the best
players what do you mean we told me to
remind you it was a Kennedy was that the
school had the best players
Kennedy I saw this in my Kevin II at one
time had when I was in the sixth grade
Kennedy had like this [ __ ] these
Street kids that went on to win a state
champion I'm five or four years wish
Maddi pick a niche challenge Remo and
somebody else and then after that like a
year later they did the same [ __ ]
thing these guys when the cow I was just
on vincible Wow Franklin had a kid my
eighth grade year that was six foot six
was leer when he was a white dude from
totally Avenue kid yeah brother they
used to call him Lili Leland that was
the original Lili yeah we are one was a
good white dude you know white dudes my
heart [ __ ] your heart
[ __ ] I had a brother that looked like a
[ __ ] model Jack Wow even back then
the brother would walk into a room with
this lady's real crazy [ __ ] boy
[Laughter]
so the Irwin brothers as they were
called were known early on
let me tell how tough Kennedy was that
David rhew is they had these two other
polar Rican kids and why do Donald and
somebody else the big game like don't
season opener yeah was the six foot six
guy against Kennedy at can place madam
everybody predicted 4head Franklin's
forwards which I got to cry they were
both six foot one Dondero and compassed
oh is it Kompas those older brother was
a coach at the ice oh wow and these guys
were big and tough and it wasn't they
were good it was that they were big and
overpowered everybody
they went into Kennedy I guess we can
they did they just broke the Irwin's leg
[Music]
they got a Porto Rican kid to come up to
me just go [ __ ] John Jones to the
ankle that's how ferocious will they
were seven three eighth grade that was
rugaard
did not [ __ ] around even up the odds and
[ __ ] around one time when I was in the
sixth or seventh grade I went to cuz you
had two games on the Thursday so it was
all four schools play games on a
Thursday okay
lucasz team play first they were up like
88
right and he was still full-court press
them in the fourth quarter like he's
like run run defense and the kids like
coach what by a thousand points it was
like Petros in the all-star he wore a
suit he wore a suit all right he wore a
[ __ ] suit this dude and he greased
his head back back in 75 in the 8th
grade he already thought he was the guy
from the Miami Riley with the suit and
the slicked back hair looking at all he
had sideburns he had red hair he wore
the vest red shirts matching shoes he'd
be out there praying Coco Espinoza this
guy dusty I mean this guy had great
[ __ ] themes right
he brought the score he didn't read that
one time that it went by a hundred you
got the playoffs I guess like Horace
Mann be the seventh grade team he likes
it on balls at their faces you made him
run backwards with the hands up for
three weeks like because they didn't win
but like that
he's showing my blood on my team let me
see I'm closer it's gets time to get
there I'm gonna have to go to a hospital
nice let me see yeah that's all over
your teeth bro it's but Joe especially
the inside yeah it's all my wife's gonna
go [ __ ] nuts last time this happened
it bled for 24 hours I had to get it
fixed in Utah oh [ __ ] I promise you
lasers [ __ ] back and I'd be so scared
how about a laser shooting my mouth he's
crazy well you're not a kid no ewtodd
did it he took like a [ __ ] piece of
metal and he goes it's gonna burn you
but though he when I put it right into
the thing that Wow Wow [ __ ]
come on I'll get 24-hour dental place
here you gotta open that door for you
uncle bleep yeah
yeah that was [ __ ] up guys so they
just a literally well how do we cover
the six six kid I know we'll break his
leg they broke this lock and we don't
have to cover him now didn't give a [ __ ]
I remember them waiting all day and
anticipation and you went to Lincoln
school right Lincoln school was the
worst they took those kids to the games
and chains all on probation like the
[ __ ] ball around their ankles
the guy from Cool Hand Luke is love him
the guy from Cool Hand Luke you've got
the rifles four years
Lincoln would show up cuz the third
floor Lincoln was known for being
[ __ ] kids or the basement was the
basement was all the retards if any
interviewer even if you were straight
and you went to Lincoln people looked at
you were ready goes to Lincoln I don't
know it was nice meeting I guess I don't
need a ride home oh yeah if you will
from Lincoln people looked at you we
that's [ __ ] great like you're zap T
they told you I go to Lincoln it took
about two days and you finally go can I
ask you a personal question
oh you open the third floor and then
they go now I'm not in the [ __ ]
basement I'm in the regular school
program but half the kids want probation
they would take him well I remember one
time we played them in the eighth grade
they had like ferny Rago but I haven't
before he did something during the week
and he had let me get a paper towel he
had a black eye and I don't know if we
got feeling so intimidated I had never
played against somebody with a black eye
before my whole thing
I never played against somebody with a
black eye I hate my whole life that's
scary when you're a kid dude right when
you see we just like somebody just like
all wounded just walking around doing
like what the [ __ ] even with the black
eye when you're a kid that's like ah
[ __ ] okay real where's this bleep old I
say yes did you put in a bag yeah I put
it in the back way I guess it got
freezer burn
there you go oh let's see you gotta give
it a shot
try everything it was better than going
home and my wife telling me to go to the
[ __ ] Hospital I'll shoot she'll make
you go after the last time I stayed up
all night believe no I got up in the
middle of night this ski mask blood oh
yeah she was livid I was putting makeup
on it I knew there was some you look
like the guy at the end of Mad Max I
knew there was something you could put
on this is Italian ice oh I'm sitting
there [ __ ] bleed Cuban ice yeah I'm
sitting there [ __ ] bleed I know this
something I put some chemical that at
this point Li what difference need to
move out here be like his medical
assistant she's been the medical field
like how like what happened you just
bite your tongue yeah I was talking [ __ ]
to you guys on a piece of gum on my mind
I stopped jounin nicotine gum that [ __ ]
so what were we talking about we have a
good conversation was going great man
basketball basketball I love I love that
her school had all the degenerates oh my
god and they were and they played here's
the catch if you went to Lincoln School
you also played for Our Lady of Libra if
you were Catholic oh wow okay so if you
were Catholic you could play for Our
Lady
have you a Jewish you can't lose you
gotta wait for this is Jewish League
this is the the what is it called the
Harlem Globetrotters
[Laughter]
JCC yeah I was and here's the beauty of
it here's a really my niece and I both
know we come from a fucked-up town we
laugh yeah there's tough to tell the
world this because at every level it
makes you laugh the guy that was in
charge of the league his name was mr.
Kappa Torah Commissioner the
Commissioner leagues name was Michigan
mr. Kappa Torah he made the schedules
and he was also a referee
everybody had everybody was had two
referees North Bergen only had one
without one guy and we play that
McKinley didn't have a gym doesn't have
a gym there was a Little League field on
19 on 76th Street that had signs up when
I was in grammar school
coming soon literally feel it to tell
you everything I'm saying where's the
where's the Little League field money
somebody stole it
everything was getting stole did they
keep the same time for the whole ten
years it was hysterical coming soon and
then they were flipping around review
coming soon repair was [ __ ] hilarious
ice why do I swear I wish I was lying to
you when I first went to McKinley from
the sixth grade to the eighth grade who
the seventh grade twice yeah that means
I did four years at McKinley never had a
blame the eighth grade was when they
finally built the gym until then you had
a shovel snow in the winter like when it
snowed it even went there shovel don't
like that Optima can we next time you're
not burning that was early [ __ ] and put
McKinley in there and look at the front
of that and look up those steps if you
lived on the other side little steps or
you had to get now here's the beauty of
it in those days they didn't have cops
what they did was they gave kids like
that one would be cops in the future
they gave him a badge with like a white
thing there was a captain there was an
assistant captain
like a lieutenant all three of them were
[ __ ] him almost right get [ __ ] with
by the other guy oh my god but they're
not gonna be tortured in our school not
only it was the Vinny negli only was
there
Vinny warhead that was uptown downtown
we have anything that got rest his soul
but I got every right to say these
things I got every right because I grew
up with Vinny negli at downtown and
angling was the crossing guard well he
was the county key what'd he do to you
I like Vinny Negley but I like his
really did to me that you can either
walk up the stairs like the regular
[ __ ] [ __ ] or down the block he's
good [ __ ] jaywalk and cut the school
side of the building right and eliminate
the steps he would blow the whistle at
you then write you up so I used to go at
him for years like [ __ ] you Vinny suck
my dick Vinny and [ __ ] and then me and
Vinny became goombazz when he was just a
geek that she was just trying to
overpower you right and then we got to
pay him get to know him he's cool yeah
we got cool and that one day the eighth
grade Vinny was doing construction work
in his backyard and the lights were out
and he jumped off the patio deck and
there's a piece of rhubarb went almost
neck he made it he made it they called
him swivel deck it was [ __ ] horrible
and he too became a fireman then he died
there why I got arrested so I'm not
goofing that's amazing that he's fine
great
that's crazy he survived that holy [ __ ]
damn dropping some knowledge I'm loving
this show loving it this is what I'm
talking about [ __ ] [ __ ] playing
through lane I'm bleeding to do that
[ __ ] Jordan when he had the flu
still putting up 50 yeah look it's right
there right let me see it it looks like
it's kind of scabbing a little bit
already good looks like it's Gavin a
little bit I think all right then it
looks like it's scabbing just a bit I
can't I'm sorry I don't give a [ __ ]
anymore I'm glad I just don't want to go
to hospital now I'm gonna have to go and
hide it from my way
[Laughter]
you'll put a little q-tip will it dry
with a q-tip real quick don't eat any
boys with a girl put two fingers on no
back-alley surgery like that like a
pension this is what you're doing in a
little bit yeah take it over they get
put crazy glue don't tip yeah oh man it
let me see it look it looks like there's
a little film of skin that's coming over
it a little bit so I think you know so
we we crazy glue it
I think the ice is just what you needed
many eye seems to be doing the job I'm
sitting in the [ __ ] emergency care in
Utah and all of a sudden it comes to me
going you know who knows the answer to
this answers to the questions and the
prisons history used to be a mystery
we're gonna work an awesome date we all
get paid the right way in full no bull
it's all kids no walking driving the
rhyme and then Stalin are you [ __ ]
kidding me Oh Oh him he went to close up
with that tonight that's an old school
for these [ __ ] and Edel sounds
good man I called John McCarthy yeah
from the UFC
Oh Big John while I'm waiting to go into
emergency kit yeah after going to this
piece-of-shit hospital twice and they'd
build me $368 for [ __ ] and gave me a
blood pressure pill and said to me a
blood pressure has to go down you gotta
wait another hour I wait at that
hospital bleeding but this was nothing
this was nothing that night guys when I
was going through it was coming out of
my mouth tip of my tongue had been
bitten off maybe it's like the really
maybe it's just scarring over or
something Oh like it seems like it's in
the same area am i one in the afternoon
they sent me home I [ __ ] him went home
I went to bed I could feel the blood
coagulated oh yeah
these [ __ ] made me wait there
for three hours I come home I tell my
wife forget about I go to bed again I
wake up there's blood everywhere take a
shower when we gonna do cancel the
weekend and you'd alright [ __ ] that
should I go on a plane I [ __ ] shut my
mouth when I went through TSA like
[ __ ] blade play that he went that
white disco he's [ __ ] yeah Yoda survives
me of my dad my mom's boyfriend right it
was like my dad he he saw the pistols
but one time they came to America he saw
him to Fort Worth Texas right and he
said and I thought it was full of [ __ ]
but I read a magazine later that said it
really happened [ __ ] Sid Vicious is
on stage and these these because these
rednecks don't want to see this [ __ ]
right so they're throwing bottles at him
one of the bottles crack Sid Vicious and
on the side of his cheek right and so
while he's playing he's just holding out
his mouth so all the blood from his
cheek pours in his mouth and he just
starts spitting it at everybody think
right and then my dad's like it was even
crazier where there's he's three chicks
in the front who are trying to catch his
blood in their mouth and I thought he
was full of [ __ ] and then I read a
magazine about the Sex Pistols only u.s.
tour and the road managers like the
craziest night was in Fort Worth Sid got
cut and he's spitting his blood in these
three chicks and trying to catch it my
dad waited till my first communion you
told me that at the first good guy damn
it I gotta go home and pray my wife is
sleeping yeah would you stop crazy ya
got a new gig I call him I call the boss
and see if she can write up a contract
to make sure I don't get liable yeah
whatever from that [ __ ] right there
right before I was when we going to
[ __ ] that doctor's office I know Big
John I'm gonna buy I bit my tongue and I
can't stop bleeding what do I do
some crazy glue I know you sure works if
some guy cut himself one time his tongue
was hanging [ __ ] effectively fixed it
that's how you fix [ __ ] Krazy Glue our
school polo Rica's yeah I take the
bullet out they put them to meet
together they put a little crazy glue I
got [ __ ] we're gonna go and see what
happens we're gonna take a chance come
on we won't use native indigenous day
burn your tongue with a lighter if you
want the way you want insult me reverse
the [ __ ] charge it will probably work
how's the response been from the Netflix
nice John woods been fine it's been good
people from other countries and shit's
crazy just having like international
people being like hey I saw your
specials I was up in Chicago at the
improv there a couple of weeks ago and
it was the first time were like it was
kind of cool like people were there
because they saw the special wasn't you
know it wasn't like packed but you know
I mean it was a good maybe good numbers
and they were had a clump was happy and
a lot of people think hey we actually
saw the special we wanted to come see
you live it was nice you know so hope it
you know it's gonna be on there for a
minute so please get a shave you get a
chance check it out it's called the
gentlemen Jerry Rocha and Gabriel
produced it you know men the best thing
about the job I have now or what my job
has become just to sit back the same way
you sit back and when you've seen me
grow over the ha man yeah
I've sat back and watch you grow and I
saw you move out of here back with
something you had domestic violence she
was yeah she chased you all with New
York she wouldn't let you watch you
wouldn't watch let you watch never tape
would happen to night I taped my special
this is [ __ ] weird you show up you
know that you're the only person who
would appreciate this cuz all my friends
this they're very cell we don't believe
in a that's right so if we taped it in
upstate right at
what in the Nyack the the levity life of
their Gabe ran it out whatever and I
thought about the Stefano I thought man
I wonder if I'd be cool if I could some
kind of a sign for Mikey you know what I
mean and and it's nothing right so I
don't have time to die just getting
ready for the special we're tape we just
had one it was literally one shot we
that was it with the 10 o'clock show
that's when we're taping and that's my
opportunity and so I was just kind of
getting ready getting ready getting
ready and we're walking over to go shoot
and his brother Joe just walks right
into the club like two hours late and he
looks just like Mike you ever seen Joe's
older brother look it was amazing but
it's like it was great like that was
such a [ __ ] kick in the ass to just
get out there and do a good job you know
what I mean it was nice but it was
really weird
just strange man it's strange how that
[ __ ] kind of happens you know and those
there's friends that you just are there
more than friends or just family and
there's always that connection there's
always gonna be something as interesting
do you believe that we have a connection
absolutely to the other side usually
that once what Deadwood dead no way
people say is [ __ ] I don't you ever
thought about that I hope it's not
[ __ ] I hope it's not bolster I'm not
that religious right but I hope that
it's not that Bowl I hope that there's
something
why do you hope it's [ __ ] I hope
it's not I hope there is something I
hope you do you know I hope you still
have a connection because I mean there's
no dude don't like okay you and I I feel
closer to you than most of my family
members right like it's just so yeah I
just why would you want why would you
want to never see that person again you
know it being like it would be nice if
when it's all over you at least get to
go say hi to home you know before they
put you on a bus to come back and be a
worm or some [ __ ] like that you know
like I hope you know what it means like
it would be mad it's well yeah that's
why I kind of have that you know I don't
know yeah I think about it sometimes
you'll be great if that worked I mean
you don't I don't know obviously nobody
knows right right because it just keeps
you know like no one's you can't know
and it's just yeah but I mean that would
be ground would I would that would suck
if I don't I don't necessarily think
there's like actual like legit heaven or
hell right right but in an instant it'd
be nice if I but maybe it's just like
because your friends and family talked
about you that's right there's beer yeah
yeah
yeah I mean I think there's something to
that I think there is something to that
you know my dad will I died when I was
three and four years when we lived in
New York City I used to tell my mom I
used to see some in the kitchen at night
right right and my mom would say what is
he wearing and I forget what [ __ ]
story I told him home and then as I got
older I always thought he would pop up
when I was a kid Telemundo had a novella
on there yeah about a family that was
rich and [ __ ] and the mother would talk
bad about the father and the father was
dead so they made some type of robot
that lived with them he come to it it
was the [ __ ] creepiest pot Hawaiian
it was only on for maybe two c''s right
I would go somewhere and watch it and my
mom wouldn't watch that [ __ ] but
somewhere I would go away to a friends
next door yes they watched that creepy
programming so for years I always
thought maybe my dad will pop up and
give me [ __ ] advices [ __ ] like that I
think that they work in a different way
absolutely it's never how you wanna
think I've always believed that there's
something out there that we have not
predecessors we have ancestors ancestors
that are out there I think when you go
up there they judge it and they decide
whether you may you'd come back and
haunt this yeah you come back and watch
all right there's got to be something
there's gotta be yeah that's what you
know that's what I believe and I and I
have no problem believing it I you know
cynical you can make fun of me all you
want I don't give a [ __ ] I there's got
to be I'm with you there has to be some
kind of something hey listen I came from
a belief I there was a couple nights I
saw like people would [ __ ] get
together and they drink a little [ __ ]
whatever like hog what diente yeah well
yeah yeah I mean growing up in an array
don't call my family course they would
[ __ ] and see spirits yeah
leatherby speaking in tongues right and
there'd be like eight people in the room
and they'd tell you about your future
and I was six or seven I'd be giggle on
my breath the whole right like what the
[ __ ] are these people doing right and
then ten minutes later something else
would happen and you know I always
believe this something what I can't put
my finger I'm with you
yeah I don't know what it is yeah I've
always said like can we talk about
Anthony and Dominic specia you know we
won we were four and three and we were
[ __ ] tighter than [ __ ] me and that kid
Anthony did everything together
we were still playing ball like after
wheels over I still played ball I would
they had 38th Street Park we were
playing against kids that were all with
us to get ready to try out for freshman
year our hopes were we both started
freshman here which we had no chance
I was cubed he wasn't so I was slow he
was slower the one that he went home to
dinner dog I go home and the next
morning they tell me got no car accident
oh he's in a coma
and he's done before the 8th grade year
is over and then we go to high school
mark my mom dies and not even a year way
is done this [ __ ] out kid no its THC
crystal now goes up to like a pack on
more one of those places out there jumps
in the [ __ ] water Hawk he paralyzes
when he hits the water and he dies yeah
so three out two other than five of
those [ __ ] do it yeah me too man
jockey and the lost I say was at
McKinley Lou Hernandez
it's variant you think about that [ __ ]
for the rest of your life that organized
sport you play it as a child I think
it's so [ __ ] important then today
again for you to have organized [ __ ]
like a North Bergen this is expensive to
have your kid no it's free 3025 house I
always walked by all these [ __ ] [ __ ]
over here down the corner here is the
YMCA yeah
Plus across the street yeah no hole
recreation says oh where am i right
right there right where the library is
you think it's something else to have a
little daycare yep for low-end families
they have a little library in there they
have a basketball wing and a lot of Evan
after report you tell Mike that Parker
oh yes you're absolutely right no no I'm
the way to Magnolia between right there
and Magnolia yeah if you go in there's a
little Civic you'd say yeah there's a
pool the pool is [ __ ] fries and even
like last week when the call I said you
still jump in there you're lucky [ __ ]
you see kids go in then go get me though
yeah there's like a little fish living
on the bottom it is crazy that place but
you know what they did do paperwork
they're gonna tell you what it is Kelly
number one [ __ ] Jemma goes and says
goodbye to the kid at the end before
they shoot it before she goes into the
before and she goes into the garden
before she leaves she goes to a park and
the guy's wife is dead that killed
himself from nirvana
oh wow she walks back then she goes and
whatever Abel Abel she goes come in and
she gives Abel a ring
that's the parkland and I'll never
forget shooting walking by there and
going wouldn't it be funny if they were
shooting so they're thinking that looks
like sons of anarchy
I didn't say sure I just kept going and
on the way back there was shooting
across the street by the church and I
went home and that was it and [ __ ]
six months later I'm watching the Sons
of Anarchy there they are at the [ __ ]
bar that's crazy and I go that's what
they were doing and they show the next
scene and she's at the church and
calling Jimmy Smits and then they show
another scene and that's a completely
different situation right it's right
there I mean all the little scenes are
right there I think that's a pee-wee
Herman rode his bike around in the park
was that big park over there wasn't yeah
I think it was let me tell you some that
park right there now after the staff to
the pool there's tennis racquets now
back there would they play there's a
little hidden agenda in between that
place in the library between that we
know tennis in the library yes can you
go back there with your kid as a woman
oh no way you're gonna be careful yeah
you better see what time you go back
there and you better make sure because
there's a little encampment a homeless
guys yep I know exactly we're talking
about you're gonna be very careful F and
they see you by yourself with your kid
and they come over and learn and try to
play with your kid you know tell me look
it's got a high kill Susie Oh Mike you
still be handy [ __ ] but there's a black
Noodlers back there who the dynamite
yeah there's a black dude back to that
been giving
- got a lot of glasses stuff in fact I
put a bag together this next nice he's a
big dude yeah he's had that same clothes
on for six months through [ __ ] heats
wrong he's like the ROI actually looks
like he's got the road warrior yeah the
real outfit I'm surprised some [ __ ]
white dude from Los Feliz hasn't found
that crop 300 on you for that outfit
like you broke it down perfectly the
holes are in the right spot the dirts at
the right place and exact zipper is
broken that we need there's blood on the
perfect location we got this black dude
is a sweetheart but you could smell him
and I wish I was lying to you could
smell four feet oh well I think an
accident actually no you're talking
about cuz I go walk past that park every
morning yeah he's always dressed up like
he has a scarf he's got a head with
little Leafs in it yeah every time I see
him I try to throw him a fin sure man
yeah
three dollars yeah we're gonna have to
get some crazy glue people listen
24-hour dentist around here is gonna
tell me Lee you're [ __ ] telling you
know they're gonna want to give me
stitches so oh yeah
are you [ __ ] crazy have you lost you
so do the laser what laser there's a
laser at the dentist I promise you don't
we know [ __ ] a piece of expensive no
whatever he has insurance listen all
they [ __ ] do is they're gonna tell me
to hold on ten minutes
let me bleed like a pig and then come
back and Stitch me yeah let me tell you
what stitching is gonna do to me okay
let me just explain to you how this
process works your entire problem look
at me like a farm is like he [ __ ] you
know number one I'm gonna sit there I'm
gonna walk in and my blood price gonna
be through 20 so I'll make you sitting
wait they're gonna torment my [ __ ]
life okay
they're gonna torment my wife while I'm
there how many blushes 240 what have you
been doing all day
well for starters I hate your [ __ ]
guts blood pressure was fine before I
walked in laptop ago yeah I went to the
doctor three o'clock was 156 over 80
when I walked in right and he goes it's
a bit high no give me ten minutes old
lady in Spanish she went back it was one
[ __ ] forty right hey I'm fine
but when I gotta go down there and all
I'm thinking about is you're gonna stop
me on stitches I know what it ready you
must found me on stitches let me tell
you with stitches and Tails and uncle
Joey's life right there I'll tell ya if
you don't get confused please do I gotta
put my tongue like a little piece of
wood okay okay I want to put my little
tongue on his own like a little monkey
like a volunteer monkey if like [ __ ]
somebody went down and put that monkey
like a rest of them their foot okay
obvious it design then they have to
shoot a needle into that place no no you
have to look at it my eyes are just
looking straight up yeah no yeah just
like that just like that I don't look at
it no no what am I looking at what am i
guys i hope i was woody with no no
listen to me
I go to acupuncture I work out my fear
needles in your back is one thing on
your time you know you got a needle in
your foot that's another thing on your
time people in my tongue is like that
black dude the chicken wing at [ __ ]
7-eleven
to go they would send them back 2,000
years you've been on the 101 and got off
on Van Nuys Boulevard yeah and you get
Isis waiting for you know I find that
you're a dreamer and there you are you
the paperwork for no reason that's
what's gonna happen a sign for a dentist
who knocks you out puts you to sleep
well he doesn't dentistry work so I
think maybe just do that that thing
looks like a cherry of asthma just like
the zip line okay they trick you Lee
they trick you're the dentist
they trick you at the dentist okay go in
there the guy takes one look in those
yeah I can put you out if you built like
[ __ ] Joe atlas you have high blood
pressure you have sleep apnea we say I
can't put you out stay away from the
ship yeah he goes no no if I put you out
you could die yeah you could die okay
well stay happy you have to stay well
then I guess you have to go for the
novocaine then no no so the guy always
has a 50/50 chance to you know why don't
you came in the door even though you
were fearful you're gonna walk in there
it's like that a long time ago
you told me about the trip to Hawaii
from the corners right yeah I was
spinning around Sun free trips to Hawaii
pay for taxes $99 and I asked you what
that was what was it it's a timeshare
scam timeshare scam okay
Sasuke you think somebody's advertised
will put you out and over Kate give me a
thousand people in there every day don't
what a great feeling
what if you want ask that's called you
ever go on to paint you you know I gotta
teach this kid something every day you
ever gonna [ __ ] newspaper and you see
you're looking for that for
the court right and also you see one
that says hunter coin blue-on-blue
zero mileage 69.95 a month by the time
you get there oh my god it's been sold
though you know we do have yeah but you
know we do have I tell you that you know
what it you know what you're like I bet
you like this is a sixty nine ninety
five it's close yeah a little more come
on we make it a deal yeah and next
anyone man guess what you're paying one
whole nine ninety five yep they [ __ ]
you ran into a Jew Avast leaving
ah okay Lee you [ __ ] learn something
you see how they get you to price leader
so when guys like you and I walk in
there they go come on guy you pass out
we got to get a professional am I still
the island just in here you know we just
can't show up here with a Puerto Rican
with a with a with a with a Filipino
with a fake paperwork we gotta show up
with somebody why don't know that they
yeah and we know the last two
anesthesiologist I have more agents I'm
still alive there you go [ __ ] yeah how
you don't believe what's going on I'm
doing all right I'm gonna say I don't
want you to put crazy glue on your
tongue check it out google it concern
crazy glue on tongue what it does work
two dollars on a bottle of great I would
you let me ask you something what type
enjoy are you I'm gonna save your life
come over here baby $4.99 or go to a
[ __ ] that sit there three hours of
your time and get screwed for 1200 bust
your [ __ ] whatever what would you do
what kind of jewy you pick a it'd be
give me a $5 off crazy cool on my tongue
why not save save you save you 1105
$1,100 if I can get Vinny warhead to put
and it'll work you just put a little
patch and you make sure it just cost you
one warhead
one warhead it's all it's gonna go
yeah he's asking the internet if it's
okay to put superglue honey it is I
think I think you might be okay
what does it say my brother Lee was so
shouldn't be okay this is like
reinforcing bad behavior it's called
American ingenuity there you go okay
berrykins getting [ __ ] sick of
getting [ __ ] screwed in the ass good
insurance you pay for what good is it's
all we they always get you like okay
some balls yeah there's always a buy
listen Lee I want you to learn some you
avoid ambulances doctors listen to me
don't matter I always want you lesson
number one
avoid hospitals at all cause every time
you walk into a house where they take a
picture you I do and it goes for the CIA
and they deliver this week [ __ ] he went
to Vegas thought he got a [ __ ] he
came back a week later with ringworm he
caught the tub on an a B&B he came back
a week little too swollen I thought that
[ __ ] down go to the clinic at the CVS
this son should take care of ano that's
like this you know why cuz it works it's
effective
you gotta go understand emergency room
you know what that's like for a guy I
can't lie to anybody I'm gonna be as
long as I can with you overly is it ii
me it's taking me close to 10 years to
work on this needle phobia had shed her
mother one night I was in weed we did a
bunch of [ __ ] coke it was the night
where oh my god it was the night way
they tell you like Jerry Roca most
likely to succeed
oh you should the honors night no I
dropped out of school
October before I got fired from the job
I took
I'm just running with these saboteur in
the daytime I have my got some part-time
job I milked that unemployment those
days you can milk unemployment for a
year and a half
of extensional extension extension those
days all you have to do it every Friday
is hop on the bus go on th Street cross
the street walk stand alive about 45
minutes maybe get to the front they give
you an envelope with cash in it you
signed off and then you handed them a
piece of paper with way you went the
last two weeks looking for a job right
and then you took that little money you
walked out you made a right up to him to
a place called Gino's which was Burger
King and Kentucky Fried Chicken put
together and only knows that [ __ ]
nobodies drop salon you're like uncle
Joey you know I'm saying and then from
there you got on the corner you cross
the street again and you went to
America's favorite head shop east west
and you went to East Western you want
him to stop banging that [ __ ] body he
went to the back of East West and there
was a section of albums Oh anybody who
had played in the city
the week before now me this wasn't on
the World Bank and Pirates of the
Caribbean yeah
this was guys Li that were going into
every single event
remember the book you gave me about
music and knew your love goes to
buildings on fire so good oh they
describe what New York City did in one
week in the mid-70s to like the mid
eighties like it on a Monday night it
was I got one night I saw prints on a
Tuesday like when you were a year old 84
I saw prints on a Tuesday he announced
it at 6 o'clock
you had the hottest album in America how
this movie in America and one night at
six o'clock werlla Brando's house
lifting weights thinking about going to
city getting like a bag of weave reefer
right and they go tonight at the rich
$15 Prince and Sheila E and a nine and
nucleus Moore's day so guys like you
guys that were lonely nerd he said oh
yeah already with 10 years ahead to had
the you know you you're still the tape
recorder they just blew like everything
was this big yeah they wore a jacket
Jesus
then they jacket and they got every show
that you found that every show the cane
hits have pretty good sound quality
guard the Ritz you know I
all the little clubs CBGB's so every
Monday that you went in there every
Monday they had and it was like legit
companies these guys were putting them
all over the city you know it's again
amazing these guys are probably making
$2 problem but hey guys like you and I
were going in I'll buy that [ __ ] for 10
mark it was $4 well I remember a brand
new one in those days with 7.7 oh yeah I
paid 7 95 to sabotage oh you're gonna
come to me with a story ha ha
and then for 4 bucks you get Sabbath at
the garden the night before that's
amazing
I still remember boy Bonzo's birthday
party it was John Bob's birthday at the
garden Wow and he celebrated at the
guard next time am i listen to him maybe
3 times went that I I never got it back
that's awesome but you could hear them
drinking and the whole [ __ ] deal oh
yeah that book was amazing is that he
talked about how like I think it started
around 72 right we're at 73 example he
says in that at that time if you have
Subway's down right on any given night
if you started like 6 o'clock by
midnight
you saw the beginning of like 5
different genres of music from hip hop
to Latin jazz to Latin rock to
electronica to punk like it was all
happening every night in New York City
is amazing just every night from Afrika
Bambaataa to the Fania all-stars to you
know the Ramones like you just saw
everything dude that was amazing I got
to tell you some I was tweet young and
naive I knew and I knew about the
popular band is that right right you
know everything was on the radio so if
you listen to WN aw you got to low down
and pretty much all that heaviest [ __ ]
yeah if you listen
WABC they gave you out the giant was
coming to test sure yeah that's what
happened John will come to New York and
do five nights at the guard every night
pack it's all about cops on every
[ __ ] corner cops on horseback you
know was like Malawi fighting Joe
Frazier that's the way it was the first
time when John came in then the who came
to New York on the whole why you tour
are you [ __ ] kidding me
and in those days again you didn't
[ __ ] you guys are lucky you guys
complain about [ __ ] you guys like I
don't yeah and it's true you guys are
getting robbed you guys gotta go online
pay for a ticket pay your fee and then
thank God he's not a middleman right and
those days was done very easy they
endemics it the night before and wne
dubby right
they said tomorrow morning at 6:00 a.m.
tickets will be available for the who
the clash and and Frank whatever Joe
answer here's the deal
New York Dolls each ticket is $25 we
need to get before you need to buy a
block of four tickets send the money
order to p.o box 6480 New York City New
York wait four weeks to hear your
approval [ __ ] you sent your money and
you waited like [ __ ] Johnny Baca ha ha
ha and four weeks later you got your
[ __ ] you got your letter with your
own check back they didn't recut your
check like animals that they are to the
way they told you thank you for sending
them but let me tell you something if
you took it the sent it right away
because you didn't have a check you got
to wake your mother back right do me a
favor ma ma
no Kelly before you ask no you want to
borrow money what are you talking about
listen I got $50 I'm gonna give you $50
boy look I need for you to cut me a
check for a hundred no no don't listen I
got an idea tomorrow only wins that one
tickets go on sale I gotta put this in
the [ __ ] I got no time to argue with you
hey Sam you gotta write this [ __ ]
check for me uh if not I'm not gonna get
the see Led Zeppelin but the smart guys
like you Jerry had a brilliant move you
had three other nerdy [ __ ] friends
right
so what you would do is let's pretend
Pink Floyd came to New York right Pink
Floyd tickets they will Unseld cuz I got
them at either Saint Peter's Prep but
one of those [ __ ] places I forgot I
want to [ __ ] him and [ __ ] them let's
pretend they played five nights
okay you got you me Kelly and Lee you
know Lee something a hundred you sent
them a hundred if we were lucky we get
four out of five nights that's amazing
but since we made a pact to go together
we're gonna go together oh for [ __ ] and
that's a beat the system baby and you
don't see this band like I did that with
Judas Priest Wow
in the summer of 80 I wasn't a really
really big Priest fan right but they
came to New York and they did something
I had never heard of they start on them
one
hot Monday in July at the Palladium [ __ ]
and they closed out the week on a Friday
Wow
I knew nothing about sets I'm not gonna
lie right right right and tell you I
knew [ __ ] but I was working my
lumberyard that I was good working like
this place called Rendell lumber and I
never knew what I was gonna do right so
I left this family you can call me an
eight in the morning oh joy Judas Priest
at the gardens playing listen no blowing
time do you want to leave seven o'clock
I'll call your dad because I would get
paid on Thursday but at that place at
that time I was getting paid every day
yeah like I was just gone the guy who
got me the job so listen if you take the
job steel right hey cuz if not they're
gonna know I was stealing yeah
if you stop stealing they don't know
money's missing that's how I got this
job on 4th like where the [ __ ] was it
two blocks before the number so Madrid
on Tunnel II Avenue right
I already saw my little story huh my
niece who blocks before my so Madrid the
new place on tummy Avenue on 48th Street
down the block from the liquor store
from the post office there if you go two
blocks down what we talkin about Wendell
lumber Wendell lumber of marine was
there good Lila Wendell London marine
was a dynamic place I went into him the
first time I went in there and they go
hey no my name is Coco Pete sent me here
for a job they gonna go upstairs
Richie's waiting me
I went upstairs it's how stupid of a
[ __ ] kid I was
I go upstairs I ask for Ritchie answered
the door he's big dude he sits me down
he shakes my hand good to see do you
know anything about wood ba ba ba ba ba
he looks like the Train yet he goes okay
I'm gonna call somebody he calls his
dude named Jack Jack come on up Jack
comes up introduces himself which stage
as I've done my one they go came in
we're gonna give you a job
you came with pretty and I references
and [ __ ] I know they go whether you want
to start like I'll start right [ __ ]
nothing okay there was a favor go
downstairs get a broom when I'm waiting
to sweep this whole area sweep my office
and sweep the stairs so I go downstairs
I get the [ __ ] broom I come upstairs
I'm sweeping and guess what there's a
domino box on the table
he goes down a little box like yeah
there's nothing else in the [ __ ]
table but a table but I'm 16 I'm
salivating from the [ __ ] man everywhere
I go I'm like [ __ ] Krazy Glue [ __ ]
was just sticking me even if I don't
want to steal it I'm gonna find a wallet
still it still went hope to go life
found their way life number 15 minutes I
had to look what was in that Domino sure
and I walk up to that table I slide that
[ __ ] box and under there was a box
filled with quarters and three stacks of
stacks oh can I take the top stack off
when I rip at 20 and they put it in my
clothes the box
can I go downstairs I was going
downstairs and it's too late I took the
trap
he doesn't write go outside to help Jack
about now away he calls me up he goes
listen you clip the toilet hey I almost
didn't get the job
Wow and I know yes I did he goes why did
you clip but I go party tonight because
you know what I like your honesty don't
do it again then I'll keep you around
Wow my word behind that's great and I
didn't steal for a month but then you
just couldn't [ __ ] oh my god it was
like stealing that's great
people would come in and go honey don't
my god you know like they were walking
first of all he but he was always out in
the movies right right which was you're
an owner of a lumberyard
that's your busiest on it you know he
would strolling around nine going all
the trucks don't with you the delivery
yeah okay so the first thing you did
when you got there at seven and like
when worked in the summer right when you
walk in there at 7:00 in the morning
there's no breakfast there was no
breakfast my uncle Joey I lived at the
benders net and I would walk from the
benders cross the street to Tony hamlin
that was a Greek [ __ ] dude that's so
buttered rolls is [ __ ] and if you ain't
of Virginia ham you shed blood right
away the eggs look kind of [ __ ] up it
was next transmission place everybody
wait there walk around with lumps around
their neck and shake the transmission
dudes walked around with the lumps
around their neck well I would come in
for the sawdust to put into the
transmission
that's how kinky they were damn so they
always say if your transmission goes
come see me we've got it so I was going
in heat and then you in there
Lee the Lee and Jerry in those days I
was 16 my mother was dead these guys
paying me eight bucks an hour and I was
going anymore
he'll load these trucks there was like a
workout from there sure I could smell
the coke and the [ __ ] poop off aapke
and the middle of beer come out of my
[ __ ] port it was early in heal but in
Jersey
I loved all that [ __ ] and once the
trucks left those were the drivers and
the assistants it was me and this guy
Jack and there was two old guys that
worked inside that were as lazy they
could like if people would come in and
go hi we're looking for this type of
glue yeah they were [ __ ] pick up the
phone and pause me like Joey was grab
enough to come and watch you guys are
ten feet away
that's how lazy along the guy was missed
tons of lead oh did you ever go to
school missed runs Aledo it was her
father god bless his soul she was very
nice she died it was a father Joe trans
alito
and the other guy was just his old guy
gentle that was an old man that would do
this and he used to complain her and
tell him [ __ ] [ __ ] come over here
take our [ __ ] job
and I just sit there and giggle the
whole time alright Jack was a great guy
from Weehawken New Jersey
problem with Jack was Jack was the first
person in all of my life that I ever saw
lose his mind we needed coke no wow I
know certain people that they jog those
this guy made them look he would go like
this he'd be talking to you and he would
stay out all night I'm Friday and not
show up to work on Saturday which in
Richie's eyes was a no-no in that job he
didn't give a [ __ ] what you did all week
do me a favor show up here on Saturdays
or busiest days no no ten I won't come
Friday J and he would show up at
Saturdays at twelve [ __ ] coke top and
even be doing this [ __ ] and they would
say what are you doing he goes I'm
I'm here to see rich I need an advance
I'm the guy who Richie's out of town
come on somebody's gotta deck me at 20
come on son oh that was the first time I
saw somebody [ __ ] creeping Wow he got
really creepy [ __ ] man and I would go in
there and I would sit there after the
delivery trucks listen to me Kelly I was
about 16 I was going out every night and
those in the past I mean it was 20 bucks
if he was a normal kid 20 bucks and you
were a pimp you could buy a girl with
six pack and [ __ ] her and hang out with
them I was going in there about 9:30
these dudes were coming and going ain't
no man we went out front they said you
were here I think oh yeah anything we
need five sheets or four by eight
half-inch on paper but we need 55 sheets
off paper you got a number for us that I
would have to do math right there like
the sheets were 80 bucks 140 apiece you
want 50 of em [ __ ] mm I mean it was
it was mind-boggling and they would go
when you throw in five pieces of no Liam
give me an extra you know 50 bucks there
was days I would walk out of there with
two three thousand dollars I was 16
years old I was paying 25 I wasn't even
paying rent at the Bender's and I was
taking that money and blowing it at the
age of [ __ ] 16 in two or three days
it was all gone
God Wow buying albums right I would go
into the city to the village like a
big-shot
hey man I would go into the city and
[ __ ] go to those places up
those places I forget what the [ __ ]
place I used to go to I would go there I
would go to place things from England
and they had every arm that will get
released here right
only the albums that got released of
England how it got really important sure
so hell-bent for leather in the end with
his really killing machine yeah yeah
yeah so buccal
online and by killing machine for like
$2,000 today if I was aboard 10 of those
things do you know man looks like Snoop
Dogg is [ __ ] were you at these next
couple weeks uh end of September I'm in
Dallas headlining the Hyannis Club
brilliant and the beginning of October
headlining Fort Worth so you got a
website yeah Jerry wrote your comedy
calm primeval bit longer yeah man we
were very proud Thank You bunny and you
kept coming up here then you would go
back yeah then you would come up and
work at the [ __ ] movie Peter would
you work store no that's in the movie
theater it's in the old movies in the
old movie theater yep and you uh thanks
I appreciate it's really cool to see
there that means a lot you see the
evolution of somebody but you on the
other side saw you know when I started
working with you you weren't seeing that
was featuring yeah and we were no paso
working for garbage headliners you would
blow him out of the water I'll never
forget that you will owe them out of
because water I was training at the
Commons yeah man I was training at the
[ __ ] candy store he would blow those
dudes out of the water and then I would
do 25-member I had 15 minutes of heat
yeah from the cloudy story
I would sure ban yourself out of there I
had never been a no pass or thousands of
times and dying on stage oh yeah
improvising on Tuesday night on military
nation' yes but you know that's where
you learn to become a [ __ ] comic
everybody no question so it's still on
Netflix
it's see it's gonna be they're hopeful
for bits called what's the beginning of
it yeah if you would gave him gave you a
break yeah yeah [ __ ] thank you buddy
[ __ ] goosebumps ah means a lot under
that kid when he was [ __ ] little
Obama bull then you moved to Austin
right no no was always always in Dallas
in Dallas and inside went to New York
and then he got mugged yeah yeah I still
stay for about another couple of months
and then I came back to Texas and I
floated between Dallas and Laredo right
and then I came out here then I was with
the first psycho remember Jersey and
then I went back to Texas because she
might be listening yeah I know a bad guy
restraining order I went to Texas for a
few months and I came back and I've been
here ever since
yeah it's been it's been amazing good
finally finally feels good you know like
okay May like you said maybe I am
knocking at the door feels yeah that's
what the dope just the way the [ __ ]
this man thanks well meet I'm gonna be
at the ice house Saturday night 7:30
show working out with uncle Joey it's
that plane and that [ __ ] simple
alright number two let me talk to you
people about something today why are you
listening to this you know what today
starts Jesus Christ but it's it's not
bleeding as months now I think it's I
think it's I think you might be avoiding
the hospital which is good my wife is
gonna [ __ ] go on the crazy glue route
it doesn't matter even with the crazy
glue someone tweeted that if you do the
crazy could lose your taste buds listen
I lost my taste buds at the Chinese
buffet was a Korean girl one time she
was stripping at this place BYOB place
and I was living in the halfway house oh
and I mean it's 1988 I'm about no no
listen what's today's date
was it that six two thousand seven six
two thousand seventeen nine
in the rainy night Wow was one of our
biggest mistakes I've ever made in my
life which is how long ago 28 years
that's one of the eight years ago
I'm sadly now I got married to that
chick that hung out with me while I was
in prison
wow man she was knocked up and I'm
married and my best man was her uncle
and the wedding starts at 1:00 they're
supposed to land the late he's got a
wedding the night before he's supposed
to land at 8 o'clock in the morning he's
delayed we're at this Catholic Church
with a bunch of white people sitting
around
uncle walks in just [ __ ] up to the
gills I hugged them when asked him
where's the package
give me five minutes I'm [ __ ] up I
just got off a plane it was [ __ ]
hysterical oh my wife will never be the
room do what was going on the priest
Father time was such a cool [ __ ]
yeah because I know all over your buddy
but you gotta get a stand this is not
good we got married we went to the
reception Nebraska was playing Colorado
it was the biggest [ __ ] game of the
year to open up the [ __ ] college
football season
my wife refused to [ __ ] even let us
walk to the back room her uncle did not
give a [ __ ] run upstairs rent on the
room took a TV out to the room carry a
damn wedding reception got a table play
the Busboys another 50 bucks to go
around the corner to the hardware store
and buy an extender that [ __ ]
plug the TV in and he wants in Nebraska
caller on the game he must have put
thousands all right on top of that he
[ __ ] that he [ __ ] he [ __ ] that
they're coming for you joy they heard
what he said about their wings he
[ __ ]
he had the extension he was a jacked-up
[ __ ] watch the game
the whole boot everybody left the dance
floor and went and watched the Colorado
Nebraska game the other staff yeah me I
thought it was hilarious I got a sense
of humor my wife not so happy my wife
even brought it up a divorce court
family yeah how's that on you
it was my side of the family I was like
I think this her on goes yeah but her
uncle we don't like your fall up off my
wife god damnit that size-14 for the
years I was [ __ ] crazy
I was [ __ ] there's no one time we came
back to visit me in Colorado we get off
the plane mmm we get [ __ ] up in the
afternoon I went to court and got three
days Office of Community Corrections I
was Alec Community Corrections that
means they couldn't piss me off the
[ __ ] tricked me I told him I'd
be out of town as five he knocked on my
door - Oh Peter I'll go in another
friend an alias I can move me hahaha
we're in their [ __ ] gak to the gills
this probation officer kept knocking dog
if people if I won't open the door well
he got in the prison says I refused to
open the door the guy left he kept
saying we know you're in there
he'll when I saw the three days later he
pissed me and I'm like what are you
talkin crazy [ __ ] Jerry no I look at her
I still remember when I went back I
robbed the [ __ ] jewelry store and I
had to hide the Sarasota Florida for
like six weeks out and I [ __ ] went
back home and she was crawling around
and I'm upstairs going up and down so we
have a little basement apartment that
was the original Voodoo Lounge yeah we
gotta wait we have a weightlifting room
in the days we had a bar a bench
we had dumbbells to do bent over rows
after it was a Puerto Rican gym but the
[ __ ] work and we stole a chair and we
took the seat off it you see the seat
yes Aaron take the seat off this Li and
take the bottom off this if it has four
legs what does this make this chair I
want you to use your four years of
creativity at Emerson College all right
say it one more time a lot of
information if this chair right four
legs right without the bottom right and
I took this [ __ ] piece of chair out
right go to Cydia what this was what
would this make it a dipping station
okay so we want our feet up and do
[ __ ] dips so we all walked around
with big red we had a Puerto Rican gym
if you ever say then the other room we
shopliftin albums from Pathmark oh wow
we took the album's and we hung the
album covers on the wall around the
whole thing from Pat Benatar to Judas
Priest hell-bent for leather and sauce
wings to destiny we put carpeting and
then we put two beds down there and that
was our bedroom class we had cable TV
Plus that was our big jump because cable
TV in those days was 995 and you had
everything when HBO oh you can knock on
next-door neighbor Mike Tabasco work for
HBO TV and for 200 you got ya darlin
plan Plus Playboy before was even yeah
you got videos directive little boys and
my head want island getting chased by
chubby white dudes from New York City
that's what you got at least be over Wow
up on the pole it was a trap he would
put the trap on in his shooting coverage
so you had cable for years then one day
the cabin went dead and you gotta call
Mikey T and he come over and climb the
pole and stuff sure but you got every
channel that's you got ping pong Suzy a
[ __ ] that wasn't even on yet don't
forget [ __ ] this Saturday night I'm
at the ice house the following Saturday
I'm an Oklahoman at the casino and then
the following week two weeks later I'm
at the Pittsburgh improv one of my
favorite clubs in the [ __ ] country
but anyway I want to talk to you people
about something like I said before ever
since I started a podcast with leaf
people always want to ask for advice on
the weekends especially gamble advice
they know that I worked for a sports
betting service and they know I know
little dumb [ __ ] things about betting
I'm saying so I got bet all the time but
I will give you a good advice about one
thing all right
I don't know who's gonna win Thursday
night I don't know who's gonna win
Friday I was gonna win Saturday no no
but I tell you what I do know why know
who the hell win if you're gonna get
beat right or wrong where it's as
important where you're bettin as what
you're bettin on so there's always
that's always what I tell people to go
with my bookie dot AG my bookie has been
in business for years their rep is
rock-solid they do hundred percent cash
bonuses so off that bar you're making
money for doing nothing and they have
the fastest payouts seriously just two
business days you know who's gonna win
right
yeah great that's phenomenal lay down
some cash and wins big today I would
only recommend the service to my
listeners that have been good to me and
my friends and the people around me
that's why I'm urging you to make your
way to my bookie dot AG you win and
guess what they pay it's that easy they
have an in-game live betting the most
rewarding player perks in the business
and an all new mobile site that makes
wagering on the go a breeze join now and
my book you will match your deposit up
to 100% bonus of your first deposit up
to $1,000 are you listening to what I'm
saying to you guys that is the deal of a
century just log on go to my bookie dot
AG and use promo code church just
advocate no advocate to activate
I love this tellers IP widows they work
it out would be to activate the offer
right visit my bookie AG today use promo
code Church CH you are CH today you play
you win you get paid all right you got
lakhs
you got money to win go to my bookie dot
AG from a good church promo code Church
I'm starting it I'm still bleeding from
my lip tongue that's how tough I am I
could have tapped out on the podcast I'm
still here my name and Jerry LaRocca my
main man Lisa at the original
[ __ ]
and my beautiful niece [ __ ] you're like
you're like didn't Lamanna you couldn't
get me down you couldn't get me down and
I couldn't get me down as always like to
use the Krazy Glue on a mission to
7-eleven send you like a big case now
why is that I know for years people get
stabbed in prison what did they do you
just dope a little [ __ ] that yellow
too bad stabbed them together for weeks
you walk around with a slant
people I love you [ __ ] thank
you very much for listening thank you
very much for supporting the church
thanks for having me buddy Gary LaRoche
chillin I said I'm very very proud of
you what's your website again Jerry
Rocha comedy calm I love you mother
brother thank you go to his website
check him while he's my brother from a
different mother if he comes to your
town check him out man this guy's deep
he's been family for years and the thing
he makes me [ __ ] laugh he's told me
one he has one of the best bits I've
ever had I know he's not doing anymore
but it was always one of my all-time
favorites if you want to hear it I'll
know
go buy a soul CDs go [ __ ] yourself have
a great weekend the church my main man
Lisa at my beautiful niece Kelly LeBrock
I love you [ __ ] stay black have
a great weekend
[Music]
you
you